Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Although his family's council flat in St John's Wood, North London was compact, Charles Frantz always opened the door to his good friend Jim Ryan whenever Jim needed a place to stay. Wednesday, August 30, 1961 was one such occasion.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。尽管查尔斯·弗兰茨（Charles Frantz）位于伦敦北部圣约翰伍德（St John's Wood）的家族市政公寓面积不大，但每当吉姆·瑞安（Jim Ryan）需要地方住时，查尔斯总是会为这位好朋友敞开大门。1961年8月30日星期三就是这样一个日子。
24-year-old Jim slept on the sofa in the sitting room, as he did every time he visited. Although the Frantz family didn't know much about Jim's background, he was an exceptional house guest, tidy, polite and friendly. Charles' wife Charlotte thought of Jim as a son. Her three daughters called him uncle and loved when he came to stay, as he spoiled them with chocolates, flowers and pocket money. During his most recent stay, Jim Ryan joined Charles and Charlotte Frantz in the sitting room where the couple were watching television.
24岁的吉姆睡在起居室的沙发上，就像他每次来访时一样。虽然弗兰茨一家对吉姆的背景了解不多，但他是一位极好的客人，爱干净、礼貌又友善。查尔斯的妻子夏洛特（Charlotte）把吉姆当成儿子看待。她的三个女儿叫他叔叔，并且很喜欢他来做客，因为他总是用巧克力、鲜花和零花钱宠着她们。在吉姆最近的一次做客期间，他加入了坐在起居室看电视的查尔斯和夏洛特的行列。
Suddenly, an alert flashed on the screen. Police were seeking an unidentified man for questioning in relation to a murder that had occurred the week prior. The alert was accompanied by a composite sketch known as an identikit of the wanted man. The identikit image showed a man with a pale face, slicked back dark hair, deep-set brown eyes and bushy eyebrows. His right eyebrow was raised, giving him a somewhat inquisitive expression. While studying the sketch, Charlotte Frantz remarked that it looked like her house guest
突然，屏幕上闪过一则警报。警方正在寻找一名身份不明的男子进行讯问，以配合调查一周前发生的一起谋杀案。警报伴随着一张被称为“特征拼图”（identikit）的通缉犯合成素描。拼图显示，该男子面色苍白，梳着向后服帖的黑发，深陷的棕色眼睛，浓密的眉毛。他的右眉高挑，给人一种略带探究的表情。夏洛特·弗兰茨在研究这幅素描时，评论说它看起来很像他们的客房留宿者……
Jim Ryan, the only exception being that Jim had blue eyes. Jim heard Charlotte, but said nothing, keeping his eyes affixed to the television. A week earlier, on August 22, 1961, Michael Gregston and his girlfriend Valerie Storey took a seat inside their favourite pub, the Old Station Inn. After ordering a pint for them both, Michael spread a map out on their tabletop. The couple worked for the Rhodes Research Laboratory. 36-year-old Michael was a research scientist and 22-year-old Valerie was an assistant. That night, they were organising a car rally for their work social club.
吉姆·瑞安，唯一的区别是吉姆长着蓝色的眼睛。吉姆听到了夏洛特的话，但什么也没说，眼睛始终盯着电视。一周前的1961年8月22日，迈克尔·格雷格斯顿（Michael Gregston）和他的女朋友瓦莱丽·斯托里（Valerie Storey）坐在他们最喜欢的酒吧“老车站客栈”（Old Station Inn）里。在为两人各点了一品脱啤酒后，迈克尔在桌上摊开了一张地图。两人都在罗兹研究实验室（Rhodes Research Laboratory）工作。36岁的迈克尔是一名研究科学家，22岁的瓦莱丽是一名助理。那天晚上，他们正在为工作社交俱乐部组织一场汽车拉力赛。
Being car fanatics, this was a task that suited them both. Along with their love of cars, Michael and Valerie shared many other things in common such as music, theatre and their work. Yet, the couple's relationship was not without controversy. Michael was married to another woman with whom he had two children. The Gregston marriage was rocky. Despite numerous attempts, Michael was unable to patch things up with his wife. He met Valerie Storey at work and the two quickly developed feelings for one another.
作为汽车狂热爱好者，这项任务非常适合他们。除了对汽车的热爱，迈克尔和瓦莱丽还有许多共同点，比如音乐、戏剧和工作。然而，两人的关系并非没有争议。迈克尔已婚，并与妻子育有两个孩子。格雷格斯顿的婚姻并不稳定。尽管多次尝试，迈克尔仍无法与妻子重修旧好。他在工作中遇到了瓦莱丽·斯托里，两人很快对彼此产生了感情。
As that relationship escalated, Michael moved out of his family home to a flat in Windsor, just west of London. He and Valerie planned to marry once Michael was officially divorced. Michael's wife was aware of the affair and didn't approve, refusing to grant her husband a divorce to remarry. Michael was certain she would come around eventually. Both he and Valerie couldn't wait to spend the rest of their lives together. At 9pm, Michael and Valerie left the old station in, in Michael's grey 1956 Morris
随着这段关系的升级，迈克尔搬出了家族住宅，搬到了伦敦正西面温莎（Windsor）的一间公寓里。他和瓦莱丽计划在迈克尔正式离婚后结婚。迈克尔的妻子知道这段婚外情并且不予认同，拒绝批准丈夫离婚以便其再婚。迈克尔确信她最终会回心转意。他和瓦莱丽都迫不及待地想要共度余生。晚上9点，迈克尔和瓦莱丽驾驶着迈克尔灰色的1956款莫里斯……
Miner. They drove towards Slough, a town 30km west of central London. The summer evening was just beginning to get dark when the couple turned down a long lane off the A4 highway that led to a cornfield. Pitcher-esque and secluded, the cornfield served as a lover's lane for couples. Michael and Valerie visited the area often. On occasion, they'd wandered down to the adjacent River Thames. On this night, they remained in the Morris Miner.
莫里斯矿工（Morris Miner）汽车离开了老车站客栈。他们向斯劳（Slough）方向驶去，那是一个位于伦敦市中心以西30公里的小镇。当两人拐入A4公路旁一条通往玉米地的长长小道时，夏日的傍晚刚刚开始变暗。这片玉米地风景优美且偏僻，是情侣们的约会胜地。迈克尔和瓦莱丽经常光顾这个地区。有时，他们会漫步到附近的泰晤士河畔。而今晚，他们留在了莫里斯矿工汽车里。
Unlike previous visits, there were no other cars in sight. Approximately half an hour later, Michael and Valerie heard a loud tap on the driver's side window. Outside was a man. He signalled for Michael to wind down his window. He then poked the barrel of a .38 caliber revolver through the opening. The man was immaculately dressed in a clean and crisp dark suit, white shirt and tie. His face was partially concealed by a handkerchief tied over his nose and mouth.
与以往的访问不同，视线内没有其他汽车。大约半小时后，迈克尔和瓦莱丽听到驾驶座一侧的车窗被大声敲击。外面站着一个男人。他示意迈克尔摇下车窗。随后，他将一支.38口径左轮手枪的枪管从缝隙中捅了进来。这名男子衣着无可挑剔，穿着干净利落的深色西装、白衬衫和领带。他的脸被一块系在鼻子和嘴上的手帕半遮掩着。
Valerie scoffed, thinking it was a joke. But Michael was noticeably concerned. He did as the man asked and handed him his keys so he could unlock the back door. Taking a seat inside, the hijacker told them in a thick, cockney accent, This is a hold up, I am a desperate man, I've been on the run for four months, if you do as I tell you, you will be alright. The man told the couple that he hadn't shot anyone before. Animated and excited, he said he felt like a cowboy pulling off a stun.
瓦莱丽嗤之以鼻，以为这只是个玩笑。但迈克尔明显感到担忧。他照那男人的要求做了，把钥匙递给对方以便其打开后门。劫持者坐进车内，用一口浓重的伦敦东区口音对他们说：“这是一场抢劫，我是个绝望的人，我已经逃亡了四个月，如果你照我的话做，你们就会没事。”这名男子告诉这对情侣，他以前没有枪击过任何人。他情绪激动、兴奋地说道，他感觉自己像个干了一票惊天大案的牛仔。
Michael and Valerie annoyed the hijacker. They kept asking what he wanted, to which he replied in a half. It's alright, there's no hurry. He ordered Michael to drive further into the cornfield. It was now pitch black. The air was still. On the man's order, Michael killed the engine and the lights. Every time Michael or Valerie attempted to glance at the stranger in the back seat,
迈克尔和瓦莱丽惹恼了劫持者。他们不断追问他想要什么，而他则含糊其辞地回答：“没事，不着急。”他命令迈克尔把车开进玉米地深处。此时外面漆黑一片。空气静止不动。在男人的命令下，迈克尔熄灭了发动机和车灯。每当迈克尔或瓦莱丽试图看一眼后座的陌生人时……
he ordered them to look straight ahead. The man made small talk as the trio sat in the car. He inquired about Michael and Valerie's relationship and asked if they were married. In return, he told them about himself. He revealed that he had been in institutions or remand homes since he was eight years old. Nearly an hour later, at 10.30, there was movement at a house nearby. The trio watched as a man emerged from the property's back door. They wondered whether he would spot the Morris minor in the cornfield.
他就会命令他们目视前方。三个人坐在车里时，这名男子闲聊了起来。他打听迈克尔和瓦莱丽的关系，问他们是否结婚。作为回报，他向他们讲述了自己的情况。他透露，自己从八岁起就一直在收容所或拘留所里度过。将近一个小时后的10点30分，附近的一所房子有了动静。三人看着一个男人从该房产的后门走了出来。他们纳闷对方是否会发现玉米地里的莫里斯矿工汽车。
The gunman warned Michael and Valerie not to say anything if he happened to approach. Moments later, the man walked back inside and closed the door. At 11.30pm, nearly two hours since the ordeal began, the gunman's hunger got the better of him. He ordered Michael out of the car and to the vehicle's boot. Taking a blanket down so his hostage would be comfortable, he instructed Michael to get in. Michael pleaded with the man, telling him that there was an exhaust leak that allowed fumes
持枪歹徒警告迈克尔和瓦莱丽，如果他碰巧走过来，千万不要出声。片刻之后，那名男子走回屋内并关上了门。晚上11点30分，距离这场磨难开始已经将近两个小时，歹徒的饥饿感占了上风。他命令迈克尔下车并走到汽车后备箱。他放下一条毯子以便人质能舒服些，并指示迈克尔钻进去。迈克尔向男子恳求，告诉他车上有排气泄漏，废气会漏进……
into the boot. He would surely die if confined in the small space for a period of time. The hijacker agreed that this was a bad idea. Instead, he forced Michael to drive the car towards London, approximately an hour's drive away. On the journey, the man told Michael to pull over at a milk machine. However, nobody had a sixpence to make a purchase, so they continued on. What should have been a 28-mile journey east soon became a drive all over the English countryside.
后备箱里。如果在这个小空间里待上一段时间，他必死无疑。劫持者同意这是一个糟糕的主意。相反，他强迫迈克尔把车开向伦敦，大约有一个小时的车程。在旅途中，这名男子让迈克尔在自动售奶机旁靠边停车。然而，谁也没有六便士硬币来购买，于是他们继续前行。原本只需向东行驶28英里的行程，很快变成了一场横跨英国乡村的漫游。
The man spoke nearly non-stop. Eventually, the fuel warning light came on, and Michael pulled the Morris Miner into a garage. He approached the elderly pump attendant, asking if he could put two gallons into the tank. He tried to covertly alert the attendant to what was happening in the car, but failed to do so. The trio drove on to Stanmore, moving away from London.
这个男人几乎说个不停。最终，燃油警告灯亮了，迈克尔把莫里斯矿工汽车开进了一家修理厂。他走到年迈的加油工身旁，询问是否能在油箱里加两加仑油。他试图借此暗中向加油工警示车内正在发生的事情，但未能成功。三人继续驱车前往远离伦敦的斯坦莫尔（Stanmore）。
There, the hijacker spotted a cigarette machine. He didn't usually smoke, but ordered Michael out and watched as he walked across the road to purchase a pack. Instead of making a run for it, Michael returned to the car, presumably so Valerie wasn't left alone with the man. The traffic had thinned considerably by the time the three drove north to St Albans and further north towards Luton. The Morris Miner then hit the A6 motorway, heading towards Bedford, approximately 60
在那里，劫持者发现了一台香烟自动售货机。他平时不抽烟，但命令迈克尔下车，并看着他过马路去买一包。迈克尔并没有趁机逃跑，而是回到了车里，大概是为了不让瓦莱丽独自一人和这个男人呆在一起。当三人向北驶向圣奥尔本斯（St Albans）并进一步向北驶向卢顿（Luton）时，交通已经明显减少了。莫里斯矿工汽车随后驶上了A6高速公路，向距离伦敦以北约60英里的贝德福德（Bedford）驶去。
miles north of London. By this stage, the man was tired and needed to rest. It was nearing 1.30am. He looked out the rear window for somewhere suitable to stop. He ordered Michael to pull over twice so he could, quote, kip a slang word for a nap. Both times, he changed his mind. As they continued past the small village of Clophill and Upper Hill, the man saw the perfect place to stop.
此时，这个男人已经累了，需要休息。时间将近凌晨1点30分。他望向后车窗寻找适合停车的地方。他两次命令迈克尔停车，以便他“小睡”（kip，俚语意为小睡）。但两次他都改变了主意。当他们驶过克洛菲尔（Clophill）和上希尔（Upper Hill）的小村庄时，这个男人找到了完美的停车地点。
He told Michael to pull off into a lay-by alongside the road. Michael didn't want to, but eventually relented. His nerves were understandable. Anyone passing by could see the name of the area printed on a sign in flashing lights. Dead Man's Hill The man told Michael and Valerie he would have to tie them up while he had a kip. He took Michael and the pair searched the boot for a suitable material to use as a restraint. If they were able to find anything, they returned to the car.
他告诉迈克尔将车开到路边的一处紧急停车湾。迈克尔本不想这么做，但最终还是妥协了。他的紧张是可以理解的。任何路过的人都能看到印在闪烁灯光招牌上的地名——“死人山”（Dead Man's Hill）。这名男子告诉迈克尔和瓦莱丽，在他小睡期间他必须把他们绑起来。他带着迈克尔在后备箱里搜寻适合用作束缚物的材料。他们找到了一些东西后，便回到了车里。
The man ended up tying Valerie's hands using Michael's tie. They pleaded with him not to kill them. He reassured the couple, if I was going to shoot you, I would have done it before now. The man then noticed a duffel bag of laundry in the front seat. He asked Michael to pick it up and pass it over. As Michael reached down, the man shot him twice at point-blank range. One bullet entered his left ear, the other his left cheek. Michael slumped over.
这名男子最终用迈克尔的领带绑住了瓦莱丽的双手。他们恳求他不要杀他们。他安慰这对情侣说：“如果我要枪击你们，我之前就已经这么做了。”接着，男子注意到前座上有一个装有换洗衣物的国民服役帆布袋（duffel bag）。他让迈克尔把它拿起来递过来。正当迈克尔弯腰去拿时，这名男子在极近的距离向他开了两枪。一颗子弹射入他的左耳，另一颗射入他的左脸颊。迈克尔瘫倒在地。
Valerie screamed, you shot him you bastard, why did you do that? To which the man replied, he frightened me, he moved too quick and I got frightened. As Valerie sobbed, the man warned, be quiet will you, I'm trying to think. They argued for nearly 20 minutes as to whether Michael should receive medical attention. The man then removed the handkerchief from his face and ordered Valerie to kiss him. When she refused, he threatened her with his gun, saying, I will count five. As Valerie turned to kiss her attacker, a truck drove by. For a few seconds, the man's face was illuminated by the passing headlights.
瓦莱丽尖叫道：“你开枪打了他，你这个混蛋，你为什么要这么做？”对此，男子回答道：“他吓到我了，他动得太快，我被吓到了。”在瓦莱丽的啜泣声中，男子警告道：“安静点好吗，我在思考。”他们争论了近20分钟，讨论是否应该让迈克尔接受医疗救治。随后，男子扯下脸上的手帕，命令瓦莱丽吻他。当她拒绝时，他用枪威胁她，说道：“我数到五。”正当瓦莱丽转过身去吻她的袭击者时，一辆卡车驶过。几秒钟内，男子的脸被驶过的前灯照亮。
The man ordered Valerie into the back seat. He covered Michael's face with a rag before raping Valerie. A few other cars passed, but none for long enough that Valerie could get another good look at the man's face. When he was finished, Valerie asked the man to take the car and drive away. He reassured her that he was in no hurry. He needed to get rid of Michael's body and asked Valerie to help him. Together, they dragged Michael from the car, dumping him by the side of the road.
这名男子命令瓦莱丽坐到后座。他用一块抹布盖住迈克尔的脸，然后强暴了瓦莱丽。又有几辆车驶过，但没有一辆停留足够长的时间让瓦莱丽能够再次看清男子的脸。完事后，瓦莱丽要求男子开着车离开。他安慰她，说自己并不着急。他需要处理掉迈克尔的尸体，并要求瓦莱丽帮他。他们合力把迈克尔从车里拖出来，扔在了路边。
The man then ordered Valerie to show him how to start the Morris Miner and change its gears. Twice he stalled, and twice Valerie had to show him how to restart the engine. Eventually, he hopped out of the driver's seat, leaving the engine running. It was 3.30am. Valerie handed him a £1 note from her raincoat and pleaded for the man to just go. He replied he would have to hit her over the head or something. He begged to be left unharmed. The man seemingly relented.
接着，男子命令瓦莱丽教他如何启动莫里斯矿工汽车以及如何换挡。他熄火了两次，瓦莱丽不得不两次教他如何重新启动发动机。最终，他跳下驾驶座，任由发动机继续运转。当时是凌晨3点30分。瓦莱丽从雨衣里递给他一张1英镑的纸币，恳求他赶紧走。他回答说，他可能得敲晕她的头或者干点别的。她哀求对方放过自己，不要伤害她。男子似乎心软了。
He turned away and walked back towards the car. When he was about six feet from Valerie, he turned suddenly and fired several bullets at her. Valerie fell to her knees and then to the ground, coming to rest next to Michael's body. The man reloaded and shot at Valerie another three times. He calmly took the driver's seat of the Morris Miner and sped off towards London. That morning of Wednesday, August 23, 1961, began as a normal workday for engineering foreman James Skillett.
他转过身，朝汽车走去。当他离瓦莱丽大约六英尺远时，他突然转身，朝她连开数枪。瓦莱丽双膝跪地，随后倒在地上，倒在了迈克尔尸体的旁边。男子重新装弹，又朝瓦莱丽开 了三枪。他平静地坐上莫里斯矿工汽车的驾驶座，向伦敦方向疾驰而去。1961年8月23日星期三的那个早晨，对工程工长詹姆斯·斯基利特（James Skillett）来说，原本只是一个普通的工作日。
He picked up a friend as usual, and the two travelled together in his car towards the town of Stratford, heading towards London. As they pulled up to a set of traffic lights in the eastern London town of Wilford, they noticed a car being driven erratically. It was a grey Morris Miner. The car swerved in its lane, narrowly missing James's car as it sped past. A crunching sound could be heard as the driver of the Morris Miner changed gears and dodged further vehicles approaching from the opposite lane.
他像往常一样接上了一个朋友，两人开着车一起朝斯特拉特福（Stratford）镇进发，驶向伦敦。当他们将车开到伦敦东部威尔福德（Wilford）的一个红绿灯路口时，他们注意到一辆汽车正在行车不稳地行驶着。那是一辆灰色的莫里斯矿工汽车。这辆车在车道上左右摇晃，在疾驰而过时差点撞上詹姆斯的车。随着莫里斯矿工汽车的司机换档并躲避从对向车道驶来的更多车辆，可以听到一阵刺耳的金属摩擦声。
James Skillett and his passenger caught up to the Morris Miner at a roundabout. Pulling alongside it, James's passenger wound down his window and James lent over him. He shouted, Are you fucking mad or something? He walked to get off the fucking road. The driver of the Morris Miner looked over and laughed before driving off. The car haphazardly drifted out of sight. Earlier that morning at 5.20, a young man named John Kerr had started work for the day. He had a job with the Ministry of Transport, counting the number of cars that passed by
詹姆斯·斯基利特和他的乘客在一个环岛追上了那辆莫里斯矿工汽车。车子并排停下时，詹姆斯的乘客摇下车窗，詹姆斯探过身去。他大喊道：“你他妈是疯了还是怎么的？把车开下他妈的路！”莫里斯矿工汽车的司机看了他们一眼，大笑了一声，然后开车离去。这辆车摇摇晃晃地驶出了视线。那天清晨5点20分，一个名叫约翰·克尔（John Kerr）的年轻男子开始了一天的工作。他在交通部找到了一份工作，负责统计经过……
a specific location on the A6 motorway near Deadman's Hill. At 6.45am, he crossed over a grassy knoll and came across the bloodied bodies of Michael Gregston and Valerie Story. Detective Superintendent Robert Acott of Scotland Yard was assigned to the murder investigation. With 28 years' experience under his belt, he was confident the perpetrator would soon be found. Details of Michael's Morris Miner were circulated throughout the press and at 6.00 that night, Detective Acott received the first break in the case.
A6高速公路死人山附近特定地点的汽车数量。早上6点45分，他走过一个草地丘陵，偶然发现了迈克尔·格雷格斯顿和瓦莱丽·斯托里的血泊尸体。苏格兰场（Scotland Yard）的侦探督察罗伯特·阿科特（Robert Acott）被指派负责这起谋杀案的调查。凭借28年的丰富经验，他坚信凶手很快就会被绳之以法。迈克尔的莫里斯矿工汽车的细节在媒体上广泛传播，当晚6点，阿科特侦探迎来了案件的第一个突破。
A man walking his dog on Avondale Crescent in Ilford spotted the Morris Miner parked on the street at an odd angle. The front registration plate was damaged and there was blood spatter inside and outside the vehicle. A local resident reported the car having been parked there since 7.45am. There were no foreign fibres, hair or fingerprints present throughout the vehicle. However, two empty 38-caliber cartridge cases were found within. They matched similar cases found at the crime scene.
一名在伊尔福德（Ilford）阿文代尔新月（Avondale Crescent）遛狗的男子发现这辆莫里斯矿工汽车以奇怪的角度停在街上。前车牌损坏了，车内和车外都有血迹溅落。一位当地居民报告说，这辆车从早上7点45分起就一直停在那里。车内没有发现外来纤维、毛发或指纹。然而，车内发现了两个空的.38口径弹壳。它们与犯罪现场发现的类似弹壳相吻合。
The next morning of August 24, housewife Audrey Willis heard a knock at the back door of her house in Old Nebworth, approximately 37 miles north of where the Morris Miner was found. According to the Guardian, Audrey opened the door to find a man wearing a long grey raincoat, dark trousers and brown shoes. He was around 30 years old with a pale and long, thin face and dark, deep-set eyes. The man inquired as to whether her husband was home. When Audrey replied that he was out, the man presented a black revolver from his pocket and forced his way inside.
第二天早上，即8月24日，家庭主妇奥黛丽·威利斯（Audrey Willis）听到有人敲她位于奥尔德内布沃思（Old Nebworth）家后门的声音，这里距离发现莫里斯矿工汽车的地方以北约37英里。据《卫报》（The Guardian）报道，奥黛丽打开门，看到一个穿着长款灰色雨衣、深色裤子和棕色鞋子的男人。他大约30岁，脸色苍白，脸型修长消瘦，有一双深陷的黑眼睛。这名男子打听她的丈夫是否在家。当奥黛丽回答说他不在时，男子从口袋里掏出一把黑色左轮手枪，强行闯入屋内。
He asked Audrey for money and something to eat. She gave him four pounds and some milk and cookies. After he had drunk the milk and pocketed the biscuits, he asked Audrey to remove her shoes and go with him to the back door. As she did as requested, the man took off. A search of the area failed to find the intruder. Detectives believed that this incident was related to the A-6 attack on Dead Man's Hill. After that evening, Cleaner for London Transport Edwin Cook was doing his job inspecting the
他向奥黛丽索要钱财和吃的。她给了他四英镑以及一些牛奶和饼干。在他喝完牛奶并把饼干放进口袋后，他要求奥黛丽脱下鞋子，和他一起走到后门。正如她所要求的，男人逃跑了。对该地区的搜查未能找到闯入者。侦探们认为这起事件与死人山A6袭击案有关。那天晚上过后，伦敦交通局（London Transport）的清洁工埃德温·库克（Edwin Cook）正在伦敦南部佩克汉姆（Peckham）的赖兰车库（Rye Lane Garage）检查公交车。
buses at Rye Lane Garage in Peckham, South London. As he searched the rear of the A-36 bus for rubbish, he lifted the back seat. According to author Paul Foot, Edwin made a habit of checking this seat on every bus he cleaned after once coming across two dead rats nestled in the space. On this occasion, Edwin Cook lifted up the seat and found a dirty handkerchief. Underneath was a fully loaded revolver and five boxes of ammunition. The gun was quickly confirmed to be the .38 caliber used in the A-6 attack. The cleaner was positive the weapon and accessories had been deposited there that day as he had
当他在A-36公交车后部寻找垃圾时，他掀起了后座。据作家保罗·福特（Paul Foot）称，埃德温养成了一个习惯：在他清洁的每一辆公交车上，只要检查过一次座位发现里面藏着两只死老鼠后，他每次都会检查这个座位。这一次，埃德温·库克掀起座位，发现了一块脏手帕。手帕下面是一把上满子弹的左轮手枪和五盒弹药。经迅速证实，这把枪正是A6袭击案中使用的.38口径手枪。清洁工确信该武器和配件是当天被放在那里的，因为他……
cleaned the same bus the night before. After busy A-36 bus travelled two routes that day throughout London. Police offered an amnesty for anyone who saw anything suspicious on the bus to come forward. Nobody did. As detectives continued to hunt for the A-6 gunman, both families of Michael Grexton and Valerie Storey were coming to terms with the attack that had forever changed their lives. Michael's wife Janet was bereft at the loss of her husband. In an attempt to take her mind off things, on August 31 she went to her brother-in-law's
前一天晚上刚清理过同一辆公交车。繁忙的A-36公交车当天在伦敦跑了两条路线。警方呼吁任何在公交车上看到可疑情况的人主动站出来提供线索。但没有人站出来。正当侦探们继续搜捕A6枪手时，迈克尔·格雷克斯顿和瓦莱丽·斯托里的家人们都在努力接受这场彻底改变了他们一生命运的袭击。迈克尔的妻子珍妮特（Janet）因失去丈夫而悲痛欲绝。为了转移注意力，8月31日，她前往姐夫位于伦敦北部的一家……
antique shop in North London. As reported in the daily sketch, she was helping her brother-in-law William set up a picture display in the storefront window when she noticed a man walking by. She grabbed William's arm and pointed to the man. He was slim, approximately 5'6", and immaculately dressed in a suit with dark hair, a pale complexion and deep, sad eyes. Janet Grexton was certain this was the man who had killed her husband as his face resembled identical images based on witness accounts of the man seen driving Michael's Morris
古董店。据《每日素描》（Daily Sketch）报道，她正帮姐夫威廉（William）在店面橱窗里摆放图片展示时，注意到一个男人从门前走过。她抓住威廉的胳膊，指向那个男人。他身材苗条，身高约5英尺6英寸，身穿一身剪裁无可挑剔的西装，留着黑发，肤色苍白，眼神深邃而悲伤。珍妮特·格雷克斯顿确信这就是杀害她丈夫的凶手，因为他的面容与目击证人根据枪击发生后几小时内看到驾驶迈克尔·莫里斯矿工汽车的人的描述所绘制的合成画像惊人地相似。
Miner in the hours following the shooting. They watched him walk into a dry cleaner across the road. William tried to calm Janet, but she couldn't be consoled. She believed she had just crossed paths with her husband's killer. A short while later, William went to the dry cleaner to inquire about the man. The manager told him that he had brought in a green suit to have tailored the week earlier. He had given the dry cleaner an address in St John's Wood and a name. Although his given name was abbreviated to an initial, William had something to work
他们看着他走进了马路对面的干洗店。威廉试图安慰珍妮特，但她根本无法平静下来。她坚信自己刚刚与丈夫的杀手擦肩而过。不久之后，威廉去干洗店打听这个男人的情况。经理告诉他，这名男子一周前曾拿来一套绿色西装要求定制。他给干洗店留了一个圣约翰伍德的地址和一个名字。虽然他给的名字缩写为一个首字母，但威廉总算有了一些线索可以着手调查。
with. It was Jay Ryan. According to the daily sketch, William did not have to wait long before he ran into Jay Ryan again. The next day, he was sitting at a cafe on Finchley Road in London when a pair of exquisitely made leather shoes caught his eye. As he looked up to see the man sporting the shoes, he realized it was the same man he had seen yesterday from his shop.
那就是杰伊·瑞安（Jay Ryan）。据《每日素描》报道，威廉没等多久就再次遇到了杰伊·瑞安。第二天，他正坐在伦敦芬奇利路（Finchley Road）的一家咖啡馆里，一双做工精考的皮鞋吸引了他的目光。当他抬头看穿这双鞋的主人时，他意识到这就是他昨天在店里见过的那个男人。
William followed the man to a florist and phoned Scotland Yard. An officer arrived and William explained the situation. The florist revealed that the man had come in to send roses to his mother, Mrs Hen Ratty. The names of Jay Ryan and Mrs Hen Ratty were taken down by Scotland Yard, but as there was nothing to link this man to the A6 attack, it was not followed up. The investigation into the A6 attack was slow. Officials admitted that they had little to go on. September 11, 1961 marked nearly three weeks after the shooting.
威廉跟着这个男人来到一家花店并报警通知了苏格兰场。一名警官赶到，威廉向其解释了情况。花店透露，这名男子进来是为了给他的母亲——汉·拉蒂夫人（Mrs Hen Ratty）送玫瑰花。杰伊·瑞安和汉·拉蒂夫人的名字被苏格兰场记录下来，但由于没有任何证据将此人与A6袭击案联系起来，因此并未进行后续跟进。对A6袭击案的调查进展缓慢。官方承认他们掌握的线索微乎其微。1961年9月11日，标志着枪击事件发生将近三周。
In Maidervale, West London, hotel manager Robert Crocker was busy inspecting the rooms of the Vienna Hotel. Robert arrived at room 24, a large basement room with multiple beds. It was unoccupied at the time. Robert gave it the once over, looking for anything out of place or missing. On one of the armchairs next to a single bed were two 38-caliber cartridge cases. Robert's first thought was to simply throw them away, but he decided to call his local police and report the finding.
在伦敦西部麦达维尔（Maida Vale），酒店经理罗伯特·克罗克（Robert Crocker）正忙着检查维也纳酒店（Vienna Hotel）的房间。罗伯特来到了24号房，这是一间有多张床铺的大型地下室房间。当时里面没有人。罗伯特粗略检查了一遍，看是否有东西放错地方或丢失。单人床旁边的一把扶手椅上放着两个.38口径弹壳。罗伯特最初的想法是直接把它们扔掉，但他最终还是决定打电话给当地警方报告这一发现。
Scotland Yard confirmed that the cartridges matched those fired from the A6 murder weapon. Hotel records were checked to see who had stayed in room 24 when Michael Gregston and Valerie Storie were abducted. Being a basement suite, room 24 was not often used. It was mainly given to travellers when the other rooms were booked out. As such, only three people had stayed there recently. One was a man who had given his surname as Repur. The second was named Frederick Durant.
苏格兰场证实，这些弹壳与A6谋杀案凶器发射的弹壳相吻合。酒店记录被调阅，以查明迈克尔·格雷格斯顿和瓦莱丽·斯托里被绑架时是谁住过24号房间。作为一个地下室套房，24号房间并不经常使用。它主要是在其他房间订满时分配给旅客。因此，最近只有三个人在那里住过。其中一人是一个自称姓雷普尔（Repur）的男子。第二个名叫弗雷德里克·杜兰特（Frederick Durant）。
The third man had stayed in room 24 on August 21, the night before the shooting. Jim Ryan In late September 1961, Charlotte France appeared at Scotland Yard. It had been a month since the A6 shooting, and Charlotte had a growing suspicion towards someone she knew well. A week after the attack, the France family hosted a longtime family friend, Jim Ryan, at their council flat in St. John's Wood. He'd slept on their sofa and was otherwise his typical self.
第三个男人在枪击事件发生前一晚（即8月21日）住在24号房间。他就是吉姆·瑞安。1961年9月下旬，夏洛特·弗兰茨（Charlotte France）出现在苏格兰场。距离A6枪击案已经过去了一个月，夏洛特对她非常熟悉的一个人产生了越来越多的怀疑。袭击发生一周后，弗兰茨一家在他们位于圣约翰伍德的市政公寓里接待了一位多年的老朋友吉姆·瑞安。他睡在他们的沙发上，表现得和往常一样。
The frantic search for the A6 gunman was well underway, and his likeness was featured on televised news reports. Charlotte France had noted the suspect bore striking similarities to Jim Ryan, but he remained silent when she mentioned it. Now, Charlotte had come forward to the police to formally implicate Jim in the crime. She also revealed his full name. James Hanratty 25-year-old James Hanratty was a seasoned petty criminal.
对A6枪手的搜捕行动正在如火如荼地进行，他的容貌特征也上了电视新闻报道。夏洛特·弗兰茨注意到嫌疑人与吉姆·瑞安有着惊人的相似之处，但当她提起这件事时，他却保持沉默。现在，夏洛特向警方坦白，正式将吉姆牵连进这起犯罪中。她还透露了他的全名：詹姆斯·汉拉蒂（James Hanratty）。25岁的詹姆斯·汉拉蒂是一名老练的惯犯。
At age 15, he began dabbling in minor crimes. By age 17, he had been put on probation for a year after taking and driving a motor vehicle without concern. Two months later, he underwent a medical examination for national service, but, according to the documentary Murder Casebook, was denied entry on the grounds of being illiterate. Following this, James Hanratty started breaking into houses and stealing property. He became adept at breaking into windows without being seen and wiping surfaces clean to remove his fingerprints.
15岁时，他开始涉足轻微犯罪。到了17岁，他在未经许可擅自驾驶机动车辆后被判缓刑一年。两个月后，他接受了国民兵役的体检，但据纪录片《谋杀案档案》（Murder Casebook）记载，由于文盲而被拒绝入伍。此后，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂开始入室盗窃并偷盗财物。他变得十分擅长在不被发现的情况下破窗而入，并擦拭表面以消除指纹。
James was caught and served time in prison, where he tried to take his own life. On release in 1957, James Hanratty told his family he was going to stop his criminal behavior. However, he soon returned to prison for stealing cars. In April 1961, James, freshly out of prison, knocked on his parents' door. This time, he assured his parents that he was done with crime for good. All he wanted was a normal and straight life. His father, overjoyed and eager to set James on the straight and narrow, quit his job he had worked for 26 years and lost his pension in order to set up a window washing business
詹姆斯被抓获并服刑，在狱中他曾试图自杀。1961年出狱后，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂告诉家人他要停止犯罪行为。然而，他很快又因偷车重回监狱。1961年4月，刚出狱的詹姆斯敲响了父母的家门。这一次，他向父母保证自己已经彻底金盆洗手。他想要的只是过上正常、正直的生活。他的父亲欣喜若狂，急于让詹姆斯走上正道，便辞去了干了26年的工作，失去了养老金，以便和詹姆斯一起创办一家擦窗户公司。
with James. They worked well together, built up a steady clientele base, and his family remarked they had never seen James so cheerful. However, James Hanratty's life as a law-abiding citizen was short-lived. Three months after the beginning of their business endeavor, James' parents took a long overdue holiday. They were under the impression that James would handle the work himself. Instead, he bailed on his job and vanished.
他们合作得很愉快，建立了一稳定的客户群，他的家人感叹从未见詹姆斯如此开心过。然而，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂奉公守法的公民生活并没有持续多久。在他们创业三个月后，詹姆斯的父母进行了一次久违的度假。他们以为詹姆斯会自己处理工作。相反，他撂挑子不干并失踪了。
He stole a car and made his way to his favorite place in the UK, Soho London. Known for its vibrant nightlife, restaurants and shops, James Hanratty loved Soho, part of London's west end. With nowhere to stay, James checked himself into cheap boarding houses and hotels under the alias Jim Ryan. As luck would have it, one day he ran into an old friend, Charles Franz. Charles offered James a place to stay in his council home in St. John's Wood. When he wasn't crashing on the Franz family sofa, James would spend a night or two in
他偷了一辆车，径直前往他在英国最喜欢的地方——伦敦苏荷区（Soho London）。苏荷区以充满活力的夜生活、餐馆和商店而闻名，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂非常喜欢位于伦敦西区的苏荷区。由于无处可去，詹姆斯以吉姆·瑞安（Jim Ryan）的化名入住廉价寄宿公寓和酒店。幸运的是，有一天他遇到了老朋友查尔斯·弗兰茨。查尔斯主动提出让詹姆斯住在他在圣约翰伍德的市政住宅里。当不在弗兰茨一家的沙发上过夜时，詹姆斯会在寄宿公寓里住上一两晚。
boarding houses. During this time, he stole approximately £2,000 worth of jewellery. Charles Franz helped by valuing the stolen jewellery before James sold it to antique dealers and willing buyers in criminal circles. After Charles Franz informed detectives that James Hanratty was the suspect they were looking for, they headed for Ireland. According to Charlotte, James had travelled there to obtain a driver's licence. Detectives flew into Dublin on September 29.
在此期间，他盗窃了价值约2,000英镑的珠宝。查尔斯·弗兰茨通过帮被盗珠宝估价来提供协助，随后詹姆斯将其出售给古董商和犯罪圈子里愿意收购的买家。在查尔斯·弗兰茨告知侦探詹姆斯·汉拉蒂就是他们要找的嫌疑人后，侦探们动身前往爱尔兰。据夏洛特称，詹姆斯去那里是为了获取驾照。侦探们于9月29日飞往都柏林。
All air and seaports to Ireland were sealed as James Hanratty's boyish face appeared in newspapers. Despite an extensive search, including speaking with a man who wrote postcards on behalf of James to send to his mother, detectives returned to England on October 5 empty-handed. At the time, James Hanratty was living it up in Soho, having returned from Ireland in mid-September. A proficient driver, James had received his driver's licence with no problems. He befriended an antique dealer and stayed in her apartment.
随着詹姆斯·汉拉蒂稚气未脱的脸庞出现在各大报纸上，所有通往爱尔兰的航空和海港均被封锁。尽管进行了广泛的搜查——包括与一名代詹姆斯写明信片寄给他母亲的男子交谈，侦探们仍于10月5日空手返回英格兰。当时，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂在苏荷区过着挥金如土的生活，他已于9月中旬从爱尔兰返回。作为一名熟练的司机，詹姆斯顺利拿到了驾照。他与一位古董商交上了朋友，并住在她的公寓里。
James spent considerable money from his proceeds of crime to buy a car. He would wine and dine women and take them to the theatre at the London Palladium. On October 5, 1961, James Hanratty's luck changed. He was at one of his favourite local hangouts, the rehearsal club, when an acquaintance told him that officers were snooping around, looking for him in relation to the A6 shooting. Pale faced and panicked, James rang his good friend, Charles Frantz. Charles tried to calm James, telling him he had nothing to worry about and to go to Scotland Yard to clear his name.
詹姆斯用犯罪所得的大笔资金买了一辆车。他带着女性饮酒作乐，带她们去伦敦帕拉丁剧院（London Palladium）看戏。1961年10月5日，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的好运到头了。他在自己最喜欢的当地聚集地之一排练俱乐部（Rehearsal Club）时，一个熟人告诉他，警察正在四处搜寻他，调查与A6枪击案有关的事情。面色苍白、惊慌失措的詹姆斯给他的好朋友查尔斯·弗兰茨打了个电话。查尔斯试图安抚詹姆斯，告诉他不用担心，并让他去苏格兰场以清白。
Hanratty abruptly hung up. Charles Frantz was dismayed. He hadn't kept James on the line long enough for his call to be traced. The following day, James Hanratty phoned Scotland Yard from a public phone booth. He spoke to Detective Acott, explaining that he was innocent. However, he couldn't come forward, as he was wanted for housebreaking, after his fingerprints had been found at a crime scene the month prior. James Hanratty told the detective he couldn't take another prison stint, but desperately
汉拉蒂粗暴地挂断了电话。查尔斯·弗兰茨感到沮丧。他没能让詹姆斯在线足够长的时间来追踪他的通话。第二天，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂从一个公用电话亭给苏格兰场打电话。他与阿科特侦探通话，解释说自己是无辜的。然而，他不能自首，因为他因上个月在一个犯罪现场发现了他的指纹而被通缉犯下入室盗窃罪。詹姆斯·汉拉蒂告诉侦探，他经受不起再次入狱的折磨，但极其渴望……
wanted the matter of his alleged involvement in the A6 attack cleared up. James then called the newspaper officers of the Daily Mirror and spoke with an assistant editor. Hanratty explained his predicament and professed his innocence, telling the editor he had a watertight alibi for the night in question. Later that night, James Hanratty made another call to Detective Acott. Acott pleaded for Hanratty to turn himself in for questioning, but again he refused. The next afternoon, Hanratty called Detective Acott again.
澄清他涉嫌参与A6袭击案的事情。随后，詹姆斯打电话给《每日镜报》（Daily Mirror）报社办公室，并与一位助理编辑进行了交谈。汉拉蒂解释了自己的困境并坚称自己无辜，告诉编辑他有案发当晚的坚固不在场证明。那天晚些时候，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂再次致电阿科特侦探。阿科特恳求汉拉蒂自首配合调查，但他再次拒绝了。第二天下午，汉拉蒂再次致电阿科特侦探。
He elaborated on his alibi further, telling the detective that he had spent the night of August 21 at the Vienna Hotel under the alias Jim Ryan. The next day, when the A6 attack took place, he had taken a train 200 miles north to Liverpool to stay with friends. He had been there for three nights before returning to London. Hanratty explained three men could vouch for him, but they would not do so as they themselves were criminals. Detectives drove to Liverpool and searched for anyone who might admit to being Hanratty's
他进一步阐述了自己的不在场证明，告诉侦探他在8月21日晚以吉姆·瑞安的化名住在维也纳酒店。第二天，也就是A6袭击发生时，他坐火车向北行了两百英里前往利物浦与朋友会合。他在那里待了三个晚上才返回伦敦。汉拉蒂解释说有三个人可以为他作证，但他们不会这么做，因为他们自己就是罪犯。侦探们开车前往利物浦，寻找任何可能承认是汉拉蒂不在场证明证人的人。
alibi. They had no luck. On October 11, four days after his last contact with Detective Acott, James Hanratty entered a cafe in Blackpool, a seaside town 50 miles north of Liverpool. Confident he'd be safe from the officers searching for him in London, Hanratty ordered a meal and took a seat near the jukebox. He bowed his head when two police officers entered the cafe. Upon exiting the cafe, James Hanratty was promptly arrested.
他们没有找到任何人。10月11日，即他最后一次与阿科特侦探联系四天后，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂走进了一家位于利物浦以北50英里的海滨小镇黑潭（Blackpool）的一家咖啡馆。坚信自己能避开在伦敦搜寻他的警察，汉拉蒂点了一餐并在点唱机旁坐下。当两名警察走进咖啡馆时，他低下了头。刚一走出咖啡馆，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂就被迅速逮捕。
He told the policeman his name was Peter Bates, but after arriving at Blackpool police station, he confessed to being James Hanratty. Detective Acott rushed to the station, arriving at seven the next morning to interview his prime suspect. Although the Hanratty family had a trusted family lawyer, James was not given the option of having him present. According to author Paul Foote, Detective Acott lent over a desk and spoke to Hanratty about the Vienna Hotel, saying,
他告诉警察自己的名字叫彼得·贝茨（Peter Bates），但在抵达黑潭警察局后，他承认自己是詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。阿科特侦探匆忙赶往警察局，于第二天早上七点到达，开始讯问他的主要嫌疑人。尽管汉拉蒂家族有一位受信任的家族律师，但詹姆斯并没有被给予让律师在场的选择。据作家保罗·福特（Paul Foote）称，阿科特侦探俯身越过桌子，对汉拉蒂谈到了维也纳酒店，说道：
I can't make it too clear how desperate your position is. I must tell you now, after you're leaving room 24 on August 22, two empty cartridge cases were found at the end of the bed you tell me you slept in that night. James replied, You're kidding me Mr. Acott, aren't you? In response, Detective Acott said, I'm not kidding you Jimmy, this is very serious business. The only other person present in the interview room was another detective who took notes
“我无法向你阐明你的处境有多么绝望。我必须现在告诉你，在你于8月22日离开24号房间后，在你跟我说你当晚睡觉的那张床的床头发现了两个空弹壳。”詹姆斯回答道：“你在跟我开玩笑吧，阿科特先生，对吧？”对此，阿科特侦探说：“吉米，我不是在跟你开玩笑，这是一件非常严重的事情。”讯问室里仅有的另一个人是另一名侦探，他负责做记录……
of what went on. When the interview concluded, these notes were not signed by or read to James Hanratty to ensure they were an accurate representation of what was discussed from his perspective. James then told the officers in his heavy cockney accent that he was off to have a good kip, explaining he was tired and could sleep anywhere. The next day, those who witnessed the Morris Minor driving in the hours before and after the shooting were asked to view an identification parade to pinpoint the offender. Standing before them, amongst several decoys, was James Hanratty.
记录事情的经过。讯问结束后，这些记录未经詹姆斯·汉拉蒂签名或宣读，以确保它们准确反映了从他的角度所讨论的内容。随后，詹姆斯用他浓重的伦敦东区口音告诉警察，他要去找个舒服的地方好好睡一觉，并解释说自己很累，在哪里都能睡着。第二天，那些在枪击发生前几小时和后几小时目击莫里斯矿工汽车行驶的人被要求参加辨认队列以找出罪犯。站在他们面前、夹在几个诱饵中间的人正是詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。
Two out of three witnesses picked James as being in the car. A third witness, the pump attendant who fuelled the car shortly before the shooting, pointed out someone else. Still, there was one other person who could shed light on James Hanratty's involvement in the A6 attack. Barely surviving the ordeal that killed her partner, Valerie Story had spent the past seven weeks in hospital recovering. After being raped and gunned down, Valerie Story lay in shock beside the body of her
三名证人中有两人指认詹姆斯在车里。第三位证人——在枪击发生前不久为汽车加油的加油工，指认了另一个人。尽管如此，还有另一个人可以阐明詹姆斯·汉拉蒂对A6袭击案的参与情况。瓦莱丽·斯托里（Valerie Storie）在夺走她伴侣生命的劫难中险死还生，过去七周一直在医院康复。在遭到强暴和枪击后，瓦莱丽·斯托里震惊地躺在男友迈克尔·格雷格斯顿的尸体旁。
boyfriend Michael Gregston. She couldn't move her legs. The killer had driven away in Michael's Morris Minor. Valerie desperately tried to get the attention of passing motorists by waving her petticoat, but she was concealed from the road by a grassy knoll. Fearing she was going to die, Valerie made the words blue eyes and brown hair out of pebbles to give authorities clues to her and Michael's assailant. After hearing Valerie's pained groans, a farm laborer discovered the couple and sought
她的双腿动弹不得。凶手驾驶着迈克尔的莫里斯矿工汽车逃跑了。瓦莱丽绝望地挥舞着衬裙，试图引起过往司机的注意，但她被草地丘陵挡住，从路上看不到她。由于害怕自己会死，瓦莱丽用卵石拼出了“蓝色眼睛”和“棕色眼睛”这几个字，为当局提供关于她和迈克尔袭击者的线索。听到瓦莱丽痛苦的呻吟后，一名农场工人发现了这对情侣并寻求……
help. Council worker John Kerr arrived and flagged down the first car that drove past, telling them to call an ambulance. It was clear to John that Michael had been deceased for some time, so he focused his attention on Valerie. John wrote down Valerie's recollection of the attack on the back of his work papers, in case she passed away before speaking with authorities. According to John, Valerie described the man responsible as a little taller than she was,
帮助。市政工人约翰·克尔（John Kerr）赶到并拦下了第一辆开过的汽车，告诉他们叫救护车。约翰很清楚迈克尔已经去世一段时间了，于是他把注意力集中在瓦莱丽身上。约翰将瓦莱丽对袭击的回忆写在他的工作文件背面，以防她在与当局交谈前去世。据约翰说，瓦莱丽将肇事男子描述为比她稍高一些，
with large, staring eyes and light, fairish hair. John turned his notes over to the first police officer who arrived, but they were eventually misplaced. Valerie's story was taken to hospital in a serious condition. Two bullets were lodged in her body. One had struck her spinal cord, paralyzing her from the waist down. This also meant Valerie couldn't feel pain from her injuries, so she was able to speak coherently to detectives.
有着一双大而圆睁的眼睛，以及浅色、偏金的头发。约翰把他的笔记交给了第一个到达的警官，但这些笔记最终被弄丢了。瓦莱丽伤势严重，被送往医院。她体内嵌入了两颗子弹。其中一颗击中了她的脊髓，导致她腰部以下瘫痪。这也意味着瓦莱丽感觉不到伤痛，因此她能够逻辑清晰地与侦探交谈。
They noted that her attacker was a man in his 30s, 5'6", with a medium build. However, inconsistencies were gradually emerging. Valerie herself had written in pebbles that her attacker had blue eyes and brown hair. One of her rescuers noted her saying that he had light, fairish hair, and the police, following their initial interviews at Valerie's bedside, reported to the press that the offender had dark brown hair and deeply set dark brown eyes. These inconsistencies would become a lingering issue throughout the investigation. No one could accurately explain why they existed.
他们记录下袭击者是一名30多岁、身高5英尺6英寸、中等身材的男子。然而，前后矛盾之处逐渐显现。瓦莱丽本人曾用鹅卵石写道，她的袭击者拥有蓝色的眼睛和棕色的头发。其中一位施救者注意到她说袭击者有着浅色、偏金的头发，而警方在瓦莱丽床边进行初步讯问后向媒体通报称，罪犯拥有深棕色的头发和深陷的深棕色眼睛。这些矛盾之处将成为贯穿整个调查的挥之不去的问题。没有人能准确解释它们为什么会存在。
Three days later, Valerie assisted in the creation of an identikit of her attacker. A second sketch was also made based on the collective recollections of all those who had seen the driver of the Morris Minor in the hours after the attack. As this sketch was an amalgamation of multiple witness accounts, it looked very different from the one Valerie provided. This was a notable flaw in the identikit process. The human expression can be very difficult to capture. If multiple people contribute their descriptions, the result is often an image vastly different
三天后，瓦莱丽协助警方绘制了袭击者的模拟画像。根据袭击发生后几小时内所有见过那辆莫里斯·Minor轿车司机的人的共同回忆，警方还制作了第二张素描。由于这张素描是多份目击证词的结合体，它看起来与瓦莱丽提供的画像大不相同。这是模拟画像制作过程中的一个显著缺陷。人类的表情很难捕捉。如果有多人提供他们的描述，结果往往会产生一张与嫌疑人实际面孔大相径庭的图像
to the actual face of the subject. Despite this issue, there was one similarity between both sketches. The offender's right eyebrow was raised higher than his left. Both images were circulated in the media in the hope someone would recognise the wanted man. The Liverpool Echo commented that each sketch was dominated by dark, staring eyes. This descriptor was withdrawn on August 31 for reasons unknown. Now, the offender had blue eyes.
与真实长相大相径庭。尽管存在这个问题，这两张素描之间还是有一个相似之处。罪犯的右眉毛比左眉毛抬得更高。这两幅画像都在媒体上广为流传，希望有人能认出这名通缉犯。《利物浦回声报》评论说，这两张素描的共同特点都是一双黑色的、直勾勾的眼睛。出于未知原因，这一面部特征描述在8月31日被撤回。现在，罪犯被描述为拥有蓝色的眼睛。
Regardless of the inconsistencies, when Charlotte France saw the sketches on television, she was overcome with a sense of recognition. The man was sitting beside her, watching the same news report. When she looked at the sketches, she saw James Hanratty. Following the arrest of James Hanratty, he was brought to Valerie's hospital bedside to participate in an identity parade. The matter was urgent, as Valerie had confided to Detective Acott. My memory of this man's face is fading.
尽管存在这些矛盾之处，当夏洛蒂·弗朗斯在电视上看到这些素描时，她涌起一股强烈的熟悉感。那个男人正坐在她身边，看着同一条新闻报道。当她看着这些素描时，她看到了詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被捕后，被带到瓦莱丽的医院病床前参加列队辨认。事情很紧急，正如瓦莱丽向阿科特侦探吐露的那样：“我对这个男人脸部的记忆正在消退。”
I'm so afraid that when confronted with the man, I may not be able to pick him out. Valerie stared intently at the twelve men standing at her bedside. For ten minutes, she scrutinised their every feature and movement. She whispered to Detective Acott, who in turn instructed the men to say the line, Be quiet will you, I am thinking. One by one, they repeated the sentence. Valerie looked at them one more time and said the number of the man she thought was her attacker.
“我很害怕，当面对这个男人时，我可能认不出他来。”瓦莱丽紧紧盯着站在她病床前的十二个男人。十分钟里，她仔细审视了他们的每一个特征和动作。她对阿科特侦探耳语，阿科特随之指示这些人说出这句台词：“安静好吗，我在思考。”他们一个接一个地重复了这句话。瓦莱丽再次看了他们一眼，说出了她认为是袭击者的那个男人的编号。
This man had said thinking instead of thinking in his thick cockney accent, just like her attacker had. As the men filed out, Detective Acott squeezed her arm and said, Well done. Valerie had picked James Hanratty. When James began housebreaking, he dyed his red hair black under the impression it would hide his identity. At the identity parade, James had very noticeable regrowth.
这个男人用他浓重的伦敦东区口音把“thinking”（思考）说成了“tinkin”，就像她的袭击者一样。当这些男人鱼贯而出时，阿科特侦探捏了捏她的手臂说：“干得好。”瓦莱丽认出了詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。当詹姆斯开始入室盗窃时，他把红发染成了黑色，以为这样就能隐藏身份。在列队辨认时，詹姆斯的头发有非常明显的新长出的发根。
After the hospital lights, his hair looked a very unusual colour. It was also heavily reported in newspapers that police were looking for a suspect who had natural red hair, but may have dyed it black. It was unclear whether Valerie had read this description prior to the parade. James Hanratty approached Detective Acott and asked him if it was fair to be put on parade with his hair in the condition it was. Acott's reply was, I did not ask you to get your hair dyed, Jimmy. If you have any complaints, you can tell the judge.
在医院的灯光下，他的头发看起来颜色非常诡异。报纸上也大量报道说，警方正在寻找一名天生红发但可能染成黑色的嫌疑人。目前尚不清楚瓦莱丽在列队辨认前是否看过这个描述。詹姆斯·汉拉蒂走近阿科特侦探，质问他顶着一头这种状态的头发来参加列队辨认是否公平。阿科特回答说：“我可没让你去染发，吉米。如果你有什么不满，你可以去跟法官说。”
Two days later, James Hanratty appeared in court handcuffed to a detective. He vehemently denied his involvement in the A6 shooting. In response to the charges, all he had to say was, Alright. Just over one month later, a magistrate sent James for trial at the Old Bailey in London. At the time, the legal system only tried someone for the most serious of the crimes they had committed if they were charged with multiple crimes. Because of this, all charges for the attack on Valerie's story were dropped, and James Hanratty only faced trial for the murder of Michael Gregston.
两天后，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂戴着手铐被一名侦探押着出庭。他对A6公路枪击案的涉案指控予以坚决否认。对于这些指控，他唯一的表态是：“好吧。”一个多月后，一名地方法官将詹姆斯移送至伦敦的老贝利法院受审。当时，如果嫌疑人面临多项罪名起诉，法律系统只会就其犯下的最严重罪行进行审判。正因如此，针对瓦莱丽遇袭案的所有指控都被撤销了，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂仅因谋杀迈克尔·格雷格斯顿一案而面临审判。
As detailed by author Paul Foot, a prison medical officer assessed the James Hanratty prior to trial. He noted, He is, in my opinion, quite fit to plead. He knows the difference between right and wrong, and must be held responsible for his actions. Crime correspondence covering the case indicated that James Hanratty would likely be acquitted due to the lack of evidence against him. The main evidence to be used by the prosecution was Valerie's story's identification of him,
正如作家保罗·富特所详细描述的那样，一名监狱医疗官在审判前对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂进行了评估。他指出：“依我之见，他完全适合出庭受审。他分得清是非曲直，必须为自己的行为负责。”报道该案的犯罪记者指出，由于缺乏对不利于他的证据，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂很可能会被无罪释放。控方将使用的主要证据是瓦莱丽对他的辨认，
the fact he used the word KIP for NAP, and his Cockney accent. Certain himself that he would be found not guilty, James signed a deal with the Daily Express for £5,000 for the exclusive to his story once the trial was over. He wrote letters through a scribe to his parents, relatives and friends professing his innocence. He assured his family that they had nothing to worry about. An excerpt of a letter taken from the book by Paul Foot reads, Well mum, I know it must be hard for you and dad right now, but I want you to have faith in me.
他用“KIP”代替“NAP”的用词习惯，以及他的伦敦东区口音。詹姆斯确信自己会被判无罪，于是与《每日快报》签下一笔5000英镑的协议，买断了他在审判结束后独家讲述自己故事的版权。他通过代笔人给父母、亲戚和朋友写信，坚称自己是清白的。他向家人保证他们没什么好担心的。保罗·富特的书中所摘录的一封信写道：“好吧，妈妈，我知道你和爸爸现在一定很难过，但我希望你们对我有信心。”
If I had done this terrible thing, I would have took my own life weeks ago. As you know, I love you and dad very much. After I left home, I was thinking of you all the time and I am not saying that just because I am in trouble. But I have got faith in my defence. They are both very intelligent men and without any doubt they know I am innocent. As I said before, please have faith in me. I will soon straighten this terrible thing out.
“如果我做了这件可怕的事，我几个星期前就会自杀。如你们所知，我非常爱您和爸爸。我离开家后，无时无刻不在想念你们，我这么说绝不仅仅是因为我陷入了麻烦。但我对我的辩护团队有信心。他们都是非常聪明的人，毫无疑问，他们知道我是清白的。正如我之前所说，请对我有信心。我很快就会把这桩可怕的事澄清。”
In order to have the case heard sooner, on January 2, 1962, it was decided that the trial would be moved from London to where the A6 murder occurred. This was a huge setback for James Henraddy. It meant the jury would be comprised of Bedford locals, many of whom had thorough knowledge of and were still outraged by the attack. The trial began on January 22, 1962, near five months after the crime. On the third day, James Henraddy shocked his defence team. He had a confession to make.
为了让案件能更早开庭审理，1962年1月2日，法院决定将审判地点从伦敦转移到A6谋杀案发生的地点。这对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂来说是一个巨大的挫折。这意味着陪审团将由贝德福德当地人组成，他们许多人对这起袭击事件有深入的了解，并且至今仍感到愤怒。审判于1962年1月22日开始，距离案发将近五个月。在审判的第三天，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂震惊了他的辩护团队。他有一个供词要交代。
James admitted he had lied to detectives about his alibi. He had not been in Liverpool with three criminals, but instead by himself in the Welsh seaside town of Rill, 43 miles west of Liverpool. He told Detective Acott he was in Liverpool as he thought his three criminal friends would vouch for him and he took a train there to offer them £250 to give him an alibi. When his friends refused, not wanting to become involved, James Henraddy was in a bind. He didn't want to say he was in Rill because there was nobody there to verify it, so he stuck with his Liverpool alibi.
詹姆斯承认他曾向侦探们撒谎，隐瞒了自己的不在场证明。他当时并没有和三个罪犯在利物浦，而是独自一人在利物浦以西43英里处的威尔士海滨小镇雷尔。他告诉阿科特侦探说自己在利物浦，是因为他以为那三个犯罪朋友会为他作证，于是他坐火车去那里出价250英镑让他们为他提供不在场证明。当他的朋友们因为不想卷入其中而拒绝时，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂陷入了困境。他不想说自己在雷尔，因为那里没有人能证实，所以他坚持了利物浦的不在场证明。
Now however, he had a change of heart. Although his legal team warned him that changing his alibi made him look guilty, James said he did not want to take the stand unless he could tell the truth. His defence barrister conceded. As far as he was concerned, James was well regarded as a good-natured, likable person. He felt it was important for the jury to meet James, regardless of his changing alibi. Valerie's story was wheeled into court in a hospital bed. The damage to her spinal cord meant that she would spend the rest of her life in a wheelchair.
然而现在，他改变了主意。尽管他的法律团队警告他，改变不在场证明会让他看起来像个罪犯，但詹姆斯表示，除非能说出真相，否则他拒绝出庭作证。他的辩护大律师妥协了。在他看来，詹姆斯一向被认为是一个性格随和、讨人喜欢的人。他觉得无论不在场证明如何改变，让陪审团见见詹姆斯是很重要的。瓦莱丽·斯托里躺在医院的病床上被推入法庭。她脊髓受到的损伤意味着她将在轮椅上度过余生。
Her testimony was read aloud, part of which included the statement. While I was facing him after he shot Mike, a car came up from behind and lit up his face. He seemed to be staring through me with very large, icy blue eyes. The defence team picked apart Valerie's recollections and the different descriptions she allegedly gave of her attacker's physical appearance, specifically the colour of his hair and eyes. All the written records of her describing her assailant had since been lost, so records of what she said could not be backed up in court. The cartridge cases found in the Vienna hotel room where James Hanratty stayed were debated
她的证词被当庭宣读，其中部分内容包含这样的陈述：“在我被他枪击后面对他时，一辆汽车从后面驶来，照亮了他的脸。他似乎透过我向远方凝视，有着一双极大、冰冷的蓝色眼睛。”辩护团队对瓦莱丽的回忆以及她据称对袭击者外貌特征（特别是头发和眼睛颜色）做出的不同描述进行了逐一反驳。由于她描述袭击者的所有书面记录在此后都已经丢失，她在法庭上的证词无法得到记录的支持。维也纳酒店房间里发现的弹壳——詹姆斯·汉拉蒂曾入住过该酒店——在法庭上进行了辩论
in court. The prosecution argued that James had bought the gun just prior to the ASIC's murder. They claimed he practiced firing some shots, leaving the casings in the hotel room. His defence argued it was an unlikely scenario. However, the courtroom was about to hear more incriminating evidence against the James Hanratty. It came from his good friend, Charles Franz. As mentioned by author Paul Foote, three days before the trial began, Charles Franz attempted
在法庭上。控方辩称，詹姆斯在A6谋杀案发生前不久购买了这把枪。他们声称他练习过开枪，并将弹壳留在了酒店房间里。他的辩护律师则反驳说，这种情况不太可能发生。然而，法庭即将听到更多对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂不利的罪证。这些证据来自于他的好友查尔斯·弗朗茨。正如作家保罗·富特所提到的，在审判开始前三天，查尔斯·弗朗茨企图
to take his own life and was admitted to hospital. His treating psychiatrist stated that his depression had been brought on by Charles introducing James Hanratty to his family. Charles allegedly told his doctor, the bastard, it could have been my dear wife and daughter who he killed. Charles appeared in court with two mental health nurses to give evidence against James and it was damning. He testified that a few weeks before the ASIC's murder, he and James had been at a dog track.
自杀并被送往医院。他的主治精神科医生表示，他的抑郁症是由于查尔斯将詹姆斯·汉拉蒂介绍给他的家人而引起的。查尔斯据称对他的医生说：“这个混蛋，被他杀的本可能是我的亲爱的妻子和女儿。”查尔斯在两名心理健康护士的陪同下出庭作证，指控詹姆斯的罪行，其证词极具毁灭性。他作证说，在A6谋杀案发生几周前，他和詹姆斯曾去过一个赛狗场。
Afterwards, they caught the bus back to London. When they hopped on, it was empty. Charles went to take a seat at the front of the bus, but James motioned for him to sit toward the rear with him. Pointing to the back seat, Charles told the jury that James said words to the effect of, this is the only seat that lifts up and it's a good hiding place. Meanwhile, the investigation into James Hanratty's real alibi received a boost when the bed and breakfast he claimed to have stayed at was identified.
之后，他们乘公车返回伦敦。当他们跳上车时，车上空无一人。查尔斯走向前排座位坐下，但詹姆斯示意他跟自己一起坐到后排。查尔斯指着后排座位告诉陪审团，詹姆斯说出了类似这样的话：“这是唯一一个座位可以掀起来的地方，是个很好的藏身之处。”与此同时，随着被声称住过的民宿被确认，针对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂真实不在场证明的调查取得了进展。
The landlady gave evidence that he had stayed there for two nights over the period of the ASIC's murder. However, she was a poor record keeper and did not have any documentation to support her claim. James described in detail the room he stayed in, including that it had a green bath. The prosecution claimed that the bed and breakfast was fully booked at the time. What they were unaware of and something the landlady reluctantly admitted at the trial was that there was an extra bed in one of the private bathrooms.
女房东出庭作证说，在A6谋杀案发生的期间，他在那里住了两个晚上。然而，她记账很潦草，没有任何文件来支持她的说法。詹姆斯详细描述了他住过的房间，包括里面有一个绿色的浴缸。控方声称，这家民宿当时已经全部客满。他们不知道、且女房东在审判中勉强承认的一点是，其中一个私人浴室里其实多放了一张床。
It was given to guests when there were none others available. It had a green bath inside. The prosecution was without a clear motive in the case against James Hanratty. As Valerie Story had been raped, it was theorized the defendant was sexually motivated. However, there was never any inkling that James behaved violently towards women. Past girlfriends testified that James behaved like a perfect gentleman. One went so far as to label him as impeccable. Other women in his life described him similarly.
当没有其他房间可用时，这张床就会分配给客人。里面确实有一个绿色的浴缸。在对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的指控中，控方没有确凿的动机。由于瓦莱丽·斯托里遭到强奸，外界推测被告是有性动机的。然而，从来没有任何迹象表明詹姆斯对女性表现出暴力倾向。过往的女友们作证说，詹姆斯表现得像个完美的绅士。其中一人甚至称他为“无可挑剔”。他生命中的其他女性对他的描述也大同小异。
When James Hanratty took the stand, he answered questions calmly and without hesitation. At one stage, the prosecution compared his features to the identikit image, saying, Hanratty, do you always hold your right eyebrow higher than your left? To which he replied, I do not know, sir, because I cannot see it. His response prompted the courtroom to fill with laughter. James told the truth about his criminal past, saying, The man who committed this is a maniac and a savage.
当詹姆斯·汉拉蒂走上证人席时，他平静且毫不犹豫地回答了问题。某阶段，控方将他的外貌特征与模拟画像进行了对比，说道：“汉拉蒂，你是不是总是把右眉毛抬得比左眉毛高？”对此他回答说：“我不知道，长官，因为我看不到。”他的回答引得法庭哄堂大笑。詹姆斯坦白了自己过去的犯罪前科，说道：“犯下这桩罪行的人是个狂人和野兽。”
I am not a man the court can approve of, but I am not a maniac of any kind. I can prove it with my past girlfriends. I am a decent, I cannot say honest, but I try to live a good and respectable life, except for my housebreakings. The trial against James Hanratty lasted 21 days. It was the longest against one defendant in British history. Over 80 witnesses were called to give evidence. On February 17, 1962, the jury retired for deliberations.
“我不是一个能让法庭认可的人，但我绝不是那种狂人。我可以拿我过去的女友们来证明这一点。我是个正派的人，我不能说自己有多诚实，但我努力过着美好而受人尊敬的生活，除了我的入室盗窃。”对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的审判持续了21天。这是英国历史上针对单一被告历时最长的审判。法庭传唤了80多名证人出庭作证。1962年2月17日，陪审团退庭进行商议。
Six hours later, they returned to ask for clarification of the phrase reasonable doubt. Another four hours passed before they reappeared. For the murder of Michael Grexton, James Hanratty was found guilty. The verdict sent shockwaves through the courtroom. The judge noticeably hesitated before delivering the sentence. James Hanratty was sentenced to death by hanging. In response, James' mother collapsed and fainted. James, visibly distressed, fell forward onto the dock.
六个小时后，他们返回法庭要求澄清“合理怀疑”这一短语的含义。又过了四个小时，他们才再次出现。因谋杀迈克尔·格雷克斯顿罪名成立，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被判有罪。这一裁决在法庭上引起了轰动。法官在宣判前明显犹豫了一下。詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被判处绞刑。作为回应，詹姆斯的母亲当场虚脱昏倒。神情痛苦的詹姆斯向前扑倒在被告席上。
He was asked if he had any final words to which he replied, I'm innocent my lord, I will appeal. That is all I have to say at this stage. Watching the chaos unfold in court was a man harboring a secret. He wanted to make a confession, but would have to wait a little longer. March 2, 1962 Dear mum, just a few lines in answer to your kind and welcome letter which I received the other day. I was very pleased to hear that you were all in good health and spirits at home.
当被问及是否有最后遗言时，他回答说：“我是清白的，法官大人，我会上诉。这就是我目前要说的一切。”正看着法庭上乱作一团的景象，有一个人心里藏着一个秘密。他很想坦白，但不得不再等上一小会儿。1962年3月2日亲爱的妈妈，简单几行字回复你前几天收到的亲切温暖的信。很高兴得知你们在家里的身体和精神状态都很好。
Things are just the same here. I am over the shock now and I am patiently waiting for my appeal, which you already know is the 12th of March and I will be looking forward to seeing you then. I have had one or two letters from different people all expressing their faith in me and the outcome of the appeal. All I ask is when I go to court that I be given a fair trial and I feel this time the circumstances are different. I have great faith in my defence, he said to me, the guilty will be punished and the innocent set free. It is clear to thousands of people not only in here that the jury has made a terrible mistake.
这里的一切都和以前一样。我已经走出了震惊，正耐心地等待我的上诉，你们已经知道上诉日期是3月12日，我非常期待到时能见到你们。我收到了一封或两封不同的人写来的信，他们都对我和上诉结果表达了信心。我唯一的请求是，当我上诉时能得到公正的审判，我觉得这次情况有所不同。我对我的辩护律师很有信心，他对我说，有罪的人将受到惩罚，无罪的人将获得自由。不仅是在这里，成千上万的人都很清楚，陪审团犯了一个可怕的错误。
I can't say at this stage that I am feeling happy, but I am keeping my spirits up and that is what really counts. Good night. God bless you all. James While James Hanradi awaited his appeal, his legal team had been busy trying to further verify his real alibi. They found an additional four witnesses who claimed to have seen a man resembling James in real at the time of the A6 murder. One recalled the strange colour of his hair, thinking it must have been a wig. However, James's legal team chose not to introduce these new witnesses at the appeal. Instead, they argued that the judge had misdirected the jury.
我现在还不能说自己感到快乐，但我一直在振作精神，这才是真正重要的事。晚安。上帝保佑你们所有人。詹姆斯在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂等待上诉期间，他的法律团队一直在忙于进一步核实他的真实不在场证明。他们找到了另外四名证人，他们声称在A6谋杀案发生时，在雷尔看到过一个长相酷似詹姆斯的男子。其中一人回忆起他头发的奇异颜色，以为那一定是一顶假发。然而，詹姆斯的法律团队选择不在上诉中引入这些新证人。相反，他们辩称法官对陪审团进行了错误的指导。
The appeal was ultimately dismissed. As detailed by author Paul Foote, as the judge announced the dismissal, a woman in a wide-brimmed straw hat rose from her seat in the public gallery. She shouted, it's not true, he didn't do it, asked the conductor of the 36th bus. Everyone froze and turned to look at her. She took her seat again. The conductor of the A36 bus, where the murder weapon was located, did not recognise the woman or understand what she meant.
上诉最终被驳回。正如作家保罗·富特所详细描述的那样，当法官宣布驳回上诉时，旁听席上一位头戴宽边草帽的女士从座位上站了起来。她大喊道：“这不是真的，他没有干这事，去问36路公交车的售票员。”所有人都惊呆了，转过头去看着她。她重新坐回了座位。谋杀凶器所在的A36路公交车的售票员并不认识这位女士，也不明白她是什么意思。
There was another female conductor who worked on that bus also. However, she was never questioned as to what the strange comment might mean. Watching from the public gallery was a man who had attended both the trial and the verdict. His friends had noticed a change in his behaviour that week. He became agitated with moments of hysterics. He had something that he wanted to get off his chest and ended up writing a letter to The Daily Express. It was published two days after James Hanratty's appeal was denied.
那辆公交车上还有另一位女售票员。然而，她从未被盘问过这个奇怪的评论可能意味着什么。旁听席上坐着一个旁听了审判和宣判全过程的男子。他的朋友们注意到他那一周的行为发生了变化。他变得焦躁不安，时而歇斯底里。他有些话如鲠在喉，最终写了一封信给《每日快报》。这封信在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的上诉被驳回两天后发表。
The letter read, I've studied the case very closely and I believe Hanratty was innocent. There has been so much confusion and doubt in this extraordinary case that I'm prepared to do all in my power to seek a reprieve. He signed it with his name, Peter Alfon. The next day, the landlady of a Doss house in Acton, London, called the police. In one of her rooms, she had discovered the body of a middle-aged man. A blue exercise book was by his body.
信中写道：“我非常仔细地研究了这个案子，我相信汉拉蒂是清白的。在这个非同寻常的案件中，有太多的混淆和疑点，我准备尽我所能寻求暂缓执行死刑。”他在信尾签下了自己的名字：彼得·阿尔丰。第二天，伦敦阿克顿一家收容所的女房东报警了。她在其中一个房间里发现了一名中年男子的尸体。尸体旁放着一本蓝色的练习本。
It contained written letters to each of his family members. The letter to his wife, Charlotte, apologised for him bringing someone he thought to be a friend but was actually a monster into their house. It was the body of James Hanratty's long-time friend, Charles Frantz. Charlotte Frantz told The Sunday Times that the family had been pestered by calls in the lead-up to Charles' death. The caller had threatened, if Hanratty dies, you die. An inquest ruled Charles' death for suicide.
里面写着给他每个家庭成员的信。写给妻子夏洛蒂的信中，他为自己把一个他以为是朋友、实际上却是恶魔的人带进他们的家而道歉。死者是詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的老朋友查尔斯·弗朗茨。夏洛蒂·弗朗茨对《星期日泰晤士报》透露，在查尔斯死前的这段时间里，他们一家一直受到骚扰电话的纠缠。来电者威胁说：“如果汉拉蒂死，你也得死。”死因研讯裁定查尔斯为自杀。
The judge refused to disclose the bulk contents of the letters Charles had penned to his loved ones. However, they were written, quote, in great bitterness and great feeling against Hanratty. Meanwhile, James Hanratty's execution date of April 4, 1962 loomed nearer. In a last-ditch effort to save him, James' legal time was over. James' legal team lodged a petition with the Home Office. They sought a pardon in light of the new witnesses that had come forward in real. On March 28, James' father handed in a petition to the Home Office.
法官拒绝透露查尔斯写给亲人们的信件的大部分内容。然而，信是用“对汉拉蒂极度怨恨和强烈情绪”的口吻写的。与此同时，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂定于1962年4月4日的行刑日期日益临近。为了拯救他的最后一搏，詹姆斯的法律团队耗尽了精力。詹姆斯的法律团队向内政部提交了一份请愿书。鉴于在雷尔出现的新证人，他们寻求获得特赦。3月28日，詹姆斯的父亲向内政部递交了一份请愿书。
It was filled with the names of 90,000 British citizens requesting James Hanratty be pardoned due to a miscarriage of justice. They were skeptical of the strength of the prosecution's evidence implicating James in the murder of Michael Greigston. Some even questioned Valerie's story's ability to recall the physical characteristics of her attacker, given she had gone through serious trauma. Many weren't convinced that she could accurately identify her rapist, as the crime happened in the dark of night, and she only caught a momentary glimpse of
上面签满了9万名英国公民的名字，要求因司法不公而特赦詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。他们对控方暗示詹姆斯参与谋杀迈克尔·格雷格斯顿的证据力度持怀疑态度。鉴于瓦莱丽·斯托里经历过严重的精神创伤，一些人甚至对她回忆袭击者体貌特征的能力提出了质疑。许多人并不相信她能准确指认出强奸犯，因为案发时正值深夜，她只是通过一闪而过的一束光短暂地瞥了
him from a passing light. Four days after submitting the petition, the Hanratty family received a letter from the Home Office. There were no sufficient grounds to provide James Hanratty with a pardon. His execution would go ahead in two days' time. When James heard of the decision, he wrote a letter to his father. It read, in part, Dear Dad, I can't say how sorry I am that this has turned out this way, but that was not my fault. It was the fault of others.
他一眼。提交请愿书四天后，汉拉蒂家族收到了内政部的一封信。没有充分的理由给予詹姆斯·汉拉蒂特赦。他的死刑将在两天后执行。当詹姆斯得知这一决定时，他给父亲写了一封信。信中部分内容写道：“亲爱的爸爸，我无法表达这件事变成这样我有多抱歉，但这并不是我的错。这是别人的错。”
I am writing this letter knowing this is my only chance to thank you and Mum for all you have done for me, and the only way I can pay my respect to you and the family is to show what kind of man I really am. Though I am about to take the punishment for someone else's crime, I will face it like a man, and show both courage and strength, and try to make you proud of your son. The night before his death, James was visited by his brother Michael. The brothers had been incredibly close since childhood, and James was particularly protective of Michael. He asked Michael to continue the quest to prove his innocence after he was gone. He was certain that the truth would come one day.
“我写这封信，是因为这是我感谢你和妈妈为我所做的一切的唯一机会，我向你和家人表达敬意的唯一方式，就是展现出我究竟是一个什么样的人。虽然我即将为别人的罪行承担惩罚，但我会像个男子汉一样面对它，展现出勇气和力量，并努力让你们为有我这个儿子而感到骄傲。”在他死前的那个晚上，詹姆斯的弟弟迈克尔来看望了他。兄弟俩自童年起就极其亲密，詹姆斯对迈克尔格外保护。他请求迈克尔在他离世后继续寻求证明他的清白。他坚信真相总有一天会大白于天下。
On the morning of April 4, 1962, James Hanratty was joined by two priests. After spending hours with the convicted killer, both priests were convinced of his innocence. They prayed together before James was led to the gallows. As his family prayed together in a nearby church, James Hanratty was hanged. Two days prior to James Hanratty's execution, housewife Audrey Willis again heard knocking on her back door. She opened it to find the same man who had forced entry into her home the day after the A-6 murder. Yet again, he wielded a black revolver. He asked for food and some money before fleeing out the back door, much like he did the first time.
1962年4月4日清晨，两名神父来到詹姆斯·汉拉蒂身边。在与这位死囚度过了几个小时后，两位神父都确信他是清白的。在詹姆斯被带上绞刑架之前，他们一起祈祷。当他的家人在附近的教堂一起祈祷时，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被绞死了。在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被处决两天前，家庭主妇奥黛丽·威利斯再次听到有人敲她的后门。她打开门，发现竟是那个在A-6谋杀案发生后第二天强行闯入她家的同一个男人。他又一次挥舞着一把黑色左轮手枪。他索要了一些食物和钱，然后从后门逃跑了，就像他第一次做的那样。
Long considered to be related to the A-6 murder, the fact that this second confrontation occurred while James Hanratty was in prison assured detectives that it must be unrelated. However, to those who believed in Hanratty's innocence, it meant something else entirely, that the A-6 murderer was still on the loose. Just before the forced entry at Audrey Willis' home, Peter Alfond left his friends in London saying he had a job to do. He returned to London the night before James Hanratty's execution and went out with some friends for dinner. He was acting strangely, telling his friends that he felt the floor was going to give out underneath him. Prone to fits of hysteria, Peter's friends
长期以来，这起事件被认为与A-6谋杀案有关，但由于这起第二次对峙发生时詹姆斯·汉拉蒂正在狱中，侦探们确信这必然毫无关联。然而，对于那些相信汉拉蒂无罪的人来说，这意味着完全不同的事情——A-6凶手依然在逃。就在强行闯入奥黛丽·威利斯家之前，彼得·阿尔丰离开他在伦敦的朋友们，称他有一件工作要做。他在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂被处决的前一天晚上回到伦敦，和几个朋友出去吃晚餐。他表现得很反常，告诉朋友们他觉得脚下的地板快要塌陷了。彼得容易歇斯底里，这让朋友们
were concerned. Lately, he seemed to be acting stranger than ever. Not much is known about Peter Alfond's childhood. His father held a respectable position as a records clerk in Scotland Yard, but he and Peter fought often, and as a result, their relationship was strained. Peter did, however, get along very well with his mother. He left school at 15 and served in the Royal Air Force briefly before leading a nomadic lifestyle as a door-to-door salesman and occasional bartender in London. An eccentric man, Peter had difficulty keeping any job for a long period of time. In 1953, he received a minor conviction for taking and riding away a motorcycle. Extremely well-read, Peter Alfond studied extensively on astrology
感到担忧。最近，他似乎表现得比以往任何时候都要古怪。人们对彼得·阿尔丰的童年知之甚少。他的父亲在苏格兰场担任档案管理员，职位体面，但他和彼得经常吵架，因此他们的关系很紧张。不过，彼得和母亲相处得很好。他在15岁时辍学，在皇家空军短暂服役，随后在伦敦过着游牧般的生活，做过上门推销员和偶尔的酒保。彼得是个行为古怪的人，很难长期维持任何工作。1953年，他因盗用并骑走一辆摩托车而被轻罪定罪。彼得·阿尔丰博览群书，深入研究过占星术
and theosophy and also had an interest in witchcraft and black magic. He had fascist beliefs and greatly admired Adolf Hitler. Although they didn't get on, Peter's father gave him a small allowance which, combined with his earnings, led Peter to live a comfortable life. With no fixed address, Peter often checked into boarding houses for a few nights at a time before moving on. Although it seemed an open and shut case for those investigating the A6 murder, James Henrady was not the first or only suspect. Four days after the attack and desperate for leads, Scotland Yard reached out to hotel staff for help. As printed in the daily sketch on August 27, 1961, their appeal read, Do you have a lodger who was not stirred out for the past few days?
和神智学，对巫术和黑魔法也感兴趣。他信奉法西斯主义，并极度崇拜阿道夫·希特勒。尽管关系不睦，彼得的父亲还是给他一笔小额津贴，加上他自己的收入，让彼得过着舒适的生活。由于没有固定住所，彼得经常在旅馆登记住上几个晚上，然后又换地方。尽管对调查A6谋杀案的人来说这似乎是一个水落石出的案件，但詹姆斯·汉拉蒂并不是第一个也不是唯一的嫌疑人。袭击发生四天后，由于急需线索，苏格兰场向酒店员工寻求帮助。正如1961年8月27日的《每日素描》所刊登的那样，他们的呼吁写道：“你们有没有房客在过去几天里一直没有出门？”
Long-term border, a school teacher named Miss Perkins, read the appeal. She spoke to her landlord at the Alexandra Court Hotel in Finsbury Park, London. She was very concerned by the behaviour of the man who boarded next to her in Room 80 on the second floor. He paced incessantly in his room, talking to himself. He also rummaged through his wardrobe all night and Miss Perkins could hear the sound of something metallic being rattled. Annoyed by the constant noise, Miss Perkins knocked on his door once to ask him to be quiet. There was no response and the strange noises continued. She noticed that since the A6 murder, the man had hardly left his room. He hadn't been to the communal dining room for a meal for four days. The man was listed in hotel ledgers as
长期住客、一名名叫珀金斯小姐的学校老师读到了这则呼吁。她与伦敦芬斯利公园亚历山大宫酒店的房东交谈。她对住在二楼80号房间隔壁的男人的行为感到非常担忧。他在房间里不停地踱步，自言自语。他还在衣柜里翻找了一整夜，珀金斯小姐能听到金属物品碰撞的声响。被持续的噪音惹恼的珀金斯小姐敲了一次他的门，请他安静点。门内没有任何回应，奇怪的噪音仍在继续。她注意到，自A6谋杀案发生以来，这个男人几乎没有离开过他的房间。他已经连续四天没有去公共餐厅吃饭了。酒店账本上登记这个男人的名字是
Frederick Durant. However, this was an alias. His real name was Peter Alfon. A detective paid Alfon a visit. He gave an alibi for the night of the A6 murder, saying he visited his mother before checking into another hotel, the Vienna Hotel. It was the same one that James Hanratty had stayed in, the one in which the 38 caliber cartridge cases belonging to the A6 murder weapon were found. Alfon admitted to staying in the basement room where the casings were found on the night of the murder. After two hours of questioning, Peter Alfon was released. He returned to the police station the following morning to ask if he could be of any more assistance. Alfon's alibi was verified by
弗雷德里克·杜兰特。然而，这是一个化名。他的真名是彼得·阿尔丰。一名侦探登门拜访了阿尔丰。他为A6谋杀案当晚提供了不在场证明，称他去探望了母亲，然后入住另一家酒店——维也纳酒店。正是詹姆斯·汉拉蒂住过的那家酒店，在那里发现了属于A6谋杀凶器的0.38口径弹壳。阿尔丰承认在谋杀案当晚住过发现弹壳的地下室房间。经过两个小时的审讯，彼得·阿尔丰被释放了。第二天清晨，他又回到了警察局，询问自己是否能提供更多帮助。阿尔丰的不在场证明得到了
his mother as well as a hotel worker who remembered Peter checking into the Vienna Hotel only hours after James Hanratty had checked out. The hotel worker recalled Alfon asking how to get to Queensway on the morning of the A6 murder. He was told the best way would be to take the A36 bus, the same bus where the murder weapon was discovered. Both the James Hanratty and Peter Alfon had similar smiles and dark colored hair when Hanratty's was died and were of similar height. But the similarities ended there. Alfon did not have a cockney accent. He had dark eyes, not blue, and he was also of a slightly heavier build. He strongly resembled the identikit Valerie's story had provided of her attacker.
他母亲以及一名酒店员工的证实，该员工记得彼得在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂退房几小时后入住维也纳酒店。这名酒店员工回忆说，阿尔丰在A6谋杀案当早询问如何前往女王大道。他被告知最好的方式是乘坐A36路公交车，也就是发现凶器的同一辆公交车。詹姆斯·汉拉蒂和彼得·阿尔丰有着相似的微笑，汉拉蒂染发后头发颜色也呈深色，两人的身高也相仿。但相似之处仅此而已。阿尔丰没有伦敦东区口音。他有着黑色的眼睛，而不是蓝色，而且他的体型也稍显壮硕。他与瓦莱丽·斯托里提供的袭击者模拟画像有着高度的相似性。
The hotel worker who interacted with the pair said in his police statement, Hanratty was at all times cool, calm and composed and left our hotel like a normal man who had a breakfast after a full night's sleep and was leaving for work. Whereas Alfon was flurried, hurried and agitated. On September 22, 1961, before James Hanratty was even identified as a suspect, Peter Alfon's mother was questioned. Under interrogation, she changed her statement, saying she hadn't seen her son on the night of the A6 attack. It had been a month earlier. Detectives were certain that Peter Alfon was the man responsible for the A6 murder. The problem was, they now couldn't find him.
与两人有过互动的酒店员工在警方笔录中说：“汉拉蒂在任何时候都表现得冷静、沉着、镇定，离开我们酒店时就像一个正常人，在睡了满满一觉并吃过早餐后离开去上班。而阿尔丰则慌里慌张、匆忙且焦躁不安。”1961年9月22日，在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂甚至还未被确定为嫌疑人之前，彼得·阿尔丰的母亲受到了盘问。在审讯下，她修改了证词，称她在A6袭击案当晚并没有见过儿子。那是发生在一个月前的事。侦探们确信彼得·阿尔丰就是A6谋杀案的真凶。问题是，他们现在找不到他了。
Police put out a public appeal to locate Alfon. Just before midnight on September 22, the Daily Mail newspaper received a call. It was from Alfon. He was in a phone booth outside of Scotland Yard and was about to give himself up. He explained that he was innocent and needed to clear his name. A reporter met him there and together they went inside. Following a detailed interrogation, detectives felt that Peter Alfon was less likely to be their man. However, to be sure, they conducted a series of identity parades. The first included witnesses who had cited Michael Gregston's Morris Minor being driven
警方发布了寻找阿尔丰的公开呼吁。9月22日午夜前夕，《每日邮报》接到了一个电话。打电话的是阿尔丰。他在苏格兰场外的一个电话亭里，打算自首。他解释说自己是无辜的，需要洗清罪名。一名记者在那里与他会合，两人一起走了进去。经过详细审讯，侦探们觉得彼得·阿尔丰不太可能是他们要找的人。然而为了以防万一，他们进行了一系列列队辨认。第一次辨认包括了一些目击证人，他们在迈克尔·格雷格斯顿被谋杀后的几个小时里，曾看到迈克尔的莫里斯·Minor轿车由一名男子驾驶。
by a man in the hours following Michael's murder. Also present was the Vienna Hotel worker who interacted with Alfon. He was the only person to pick Alfon from the lineup. A lineup featuring Peter Alfon was also presented to Valerie Story while she recovered in hospital. Her eyes slowly travelled across each person several times. Alfon spoke of the experience to the Daily Express. Quote, It dawned on me that she wasn't quite sure of herself. I began to get hot under the collar. Eventually, her gaze fell on me and stayed. Suddenly, she spoke. It was not my number. Valerie pointed to another man. When she was told that it wasn't the person they were
与阿尔丰有过接触的维也纳酒店员工也在场。他是唯一一个从列队中认出阿尔丰的人。在瓦莱丽·斯托里于医院康复期间，警方也向她展示了包含彼得·阿尔丰的列队辨认。她的目光缓缓扫过每个人好几次。阿尔丰向《每日快报》谈及了当时的经历。原话是：“我突然意识到她自己也拿不定主意。我开始感到有些心焦。最终，她的目光落在我身上并停了下来。突然，她开口了。那不是我的编号。”瓦莱丽指向了另一个人。当被告知这并非他们
suspecting in the A6 murder, she broke down sobbing and said, I made a mistake. As a result, Peter Alfon was dropped as a suspect. From then on, detectives had their sights set on James Henrady. Peter Alfon was released. He spent hours pouring over the case, long after the trial and execution of James Henrady. On the one year anniversary of the A6 murder, James Henrady's parents heard a knock at their door. They let the stranger inside and he took a seat in their lounge room. He began speaking about James and how he didn't believe there was enough evidence to convict him. He told the Henrady's that he wanted to
在A6谋杀案中怀疑的人时，她放声大哭，并说道：“我弄错了。”因此，彼得·阿尔丰被排除了嫌疑人名单。从那时起，侦探们将目标锁定了詹姆斯·汉拉蒂。彼得·阿尔丰被释放了。在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂受审和被处决很久之后，他仍花了好几个小时仔细研究这个案子。在A6谋杀案发生一周年之际，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的父母听到有人敲门。他们让陌生人进了屋，陌生人在客厅里坐了下来。他开始谈论詹姆斯以及他认为没有足够证据将他定罪的看法。他告诉汉拉蒂夫妇他想
write a book about what had happened. It was Peter Alfon. Taking out his checkbook, Peter offered to compensate the Henrady's for what had been done to them. The flabbergasted Henrady's became irate. They asked Peter to leave them alone. He left without incident. A few months later, James Henrady's family began getting hang up phone calls. They were mostly filled with silence. But on one occasion, late at night in January 1963, Mrs. Henrady picked up the phone. The voice on the line said, I am the A6 killer, Mrs. Henrady, and I am coming to get you. Peter Alfon continued to bother the Henrady's over the coming years.
写一本关于所发生事情的书。这个人正是彼得·阿尔丰。彼得掏出支票簿，提出要对汉拉蒂夫妇所遭受的不幸进行赔偿。震惊的汉拉蒂夫妇勃然大怒。他们要求彼得离开，不要再纠缠他们。彼得随即离去，没有发生意外。几个月后，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的家人开始接到挂断电话。电话那头大多是一片沉默。但在1963年1月深夜的一次偶遇中，汉拉蒂太太接起了电话。线那头的声音说：“我是A6杀手，汉拉蒂太太，我来抓你了。”在随后的几年里，彼得·阿尔丰继续纠缠着汉拉蒂一家。
He also chatted to his friends about the case incessantly. In 1966, there was an overhaul of a previous law that hanged men could not be buried in a civilian cemetery. As a result, on February 22, 1966, James Henrady was exhumed from the Bedford prison grounds and reburied in Wembley Cemetery. A plainclothed policeman watched on in case Peter Alfon tried to interrupt proceedings. Later that year, Valerie Story appeared on TV program Panorama to break her silence. She threw her support behind James Henrady's conviction, telling the interviewer, I was there. I was on Deadman's Hill, and I knew it was Henrady. On May 11, 1967, just over five years after James Henrady's death,
他还不停地和朋友们闲聊这个案子。1966年，有关被处决的死囚不得安葬在平民公墓的旧法律进行了重大修改。因此，1966年2月22日，詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的遗体从贝德福德监狱墓地起出，重新安葬在温布利公墓。一名便衣警察在旁监视，以防彼得·阿尔丰试图干扰仪式。同年晚些时候，瓦莱丽·斯托里出现在电视节目《全景》上，打破了她的沉默。她公开支持对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的有罪判决，对采访者说：“我在那里。我在死人山，我知道那就是汉拉蒂。”1967年5月11日，在詹姆斯·汉拉蒂死后五年多，
reporters from all over the world crammed into the Hotel de Louvre reception room in Paris, France. Alongside them were two representatives from Scotland Yard. Everyone waited with bated breath as Peter Alfon entered the room. Earlier in the day, he had phoned a Daily Mirror correspondent telling him that he was going to hold a very important press conference about the A6 murder. A hush descended as Alfon began to speak. According to the book Who Killed Henrady by Paul Foot, Alfon confessed to being the A6 murderer. He told the stunned reporters, A man offered me a large sum of money and told me to end the relationship between Michael Gregston and Valerie Story. Another man, a mutual friend,
来自世界各地的记者挤满了法国巴黎卢浮宫酒店的接待室。与他们并肩而立的还有来自苏格兰场的两名代表。随着彼得·阿尔丰走进房间，所有人都屏住了呼吸。当天早些时候，他给《每日镜报》的一位记者打电话，称他将就A6谋杀案举行一次非常重要的记者招待会。随着阿尔丰开始发言，现场一片死寂。根据保罗·富特所著的《谁杀了汉拉蒂》一书，阿尔丰承认自己就是A6谋杀案的凶手。他向震惊的记者们透露：“一个男人出了一大笔钱，让我终结迈克尔·格雷格斯顿和瓦莱丽·斯托里之间的关系。另一个男人，一个共同的朋友，
then put a gun in my hand. I was not told in so many words to murder. It was just said, we will get you a gun. Take it from there. I gave the couple in the car two chances. I spoke a lot of rubbish about morality, and I gave Gregston two chances to go away, but each time the bloody man came back. He alleged that James Henrady had been framed in the attack. The gun had been given to Alfon by Charles France, who also disposed of it on the back of the bus. Charles, who was a well-known friend of James Henrady and implicated James at trial, had since taken his own life. British newspapers initially covered the conference with some interest. However,
然后把一把枪塞到我手里。没有明说要我去谋杀。只是说，我们会给你弄把枪。看着办吧。我给了车里的那对男女两次机会。我说了许多关于道德的废话，我给了格雷格斯顿两次离开的机会，但每次这个该死的家伙又回来了。”他声称詹姆斯·汉拉蒂在袭击案中遭到了陷害。凶器是查尔斯·弗朗茨交给阿尔丰的，查尔斯后来也将凶器扔在公交车后面。查尔斯是詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的知名朋友，并在审判中指证了詹姆斯，此后他已经自杀身亡。英国报纸最初以一定兴趣报道了这次新闻发布会。然而，
the confession was not taken seriously by Scotland Yard. They refused to sway from the belief they had arrested the correct man. Having previously confessed to his friends, who had even taken a written confession to the home office, Peter Alfon was certain this public admission would lead to his arrest. The arrest, however, never came. Support for James Henrady continued to grow following Peter Alfon's public confession. The A6 murder committee was founded, which included James's close family and friends, as well as members of the public who believed in his innocence. The committee travelled to Ril and took an advertisement out in the local paper titled
苏格兰场并没有认真对待这份自供。他们拒绝动摇他们抓对了人的坚定信念。由于此前曾向朋友们坦白，而朋友甚至还把一份书面供词带到了内政部，彼得·阿尔丰确信这次公开供认会促使警方将他逮捕。然而，逮捕最终并没有到来。在彼得·阿尔丰公开认罪后，对詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的支持继续增长。A6谋杀案委员会宣告成立，其中包括詹姆斯的至亲好友，以及相信他无罪的社会公众。该委员会前往雷尔，并在当地报纸上刊登了一则广告，题为
Can You Help Mr and Mrs. Henrady Clear Their Son's Name? They called for anyone who had seen James Henrady over the days of the A6 murder to come forward. Eleven witnesses in total approached the committee to confirm their siding of James Henrady in Ril, including a family who stated he inquired about staying at their bed and breakfast. Throughout 1969, the A6 murder committee held a meeting in Hyde Park every Sunday. With Pickett's proclaiming Henrady's innocence and naming Peter Alfon as the real murderer, they paraded around the park, outside the House of Commons, and even in front of Peter Alfon's parents' house. In November 1969, Mr. and Mrs. Henrady went to stay with their nephew in Ascot.
“你们能帮mr and mrs hanratty还他们的儿子一个清白吗？”他们呼吁任何在A6谋杀案发生期间见过詹姆斯·汉拉蒂的人站出来。总共有十一名证人向委员会走来，证实他们在雷尔见过詹姆斯·汉拉蒂，其中包括一个家庭，他们表示詹姆斯曾询问过是否能在他们的民宿住宿。整个1969年，A6谋杀案委员会每个星期天都在海德公园举行集会。抗议者们高喊着汉拉蒂无罪的口号，并指名彼得·阿尔丰才是真正的凶手，他们在公园四周游行，前往下议院外，甚至走到彼得·阿尔丰父母的房子前示威。1969年11月，汉拉蒂夫妇前往阿斯科特与他们的侄子同住。
He said he would put them in touch with his wealthy neighbours who were interested in James's case. On December 9, 1969, the Henrady's met with their nephew's wealthy neighbours. John Lennon and Yoko Ono The former Beatles band member was intrigued by the case and spoke at length about it to Mr and Mrs. Henrady. They wanted to make a film about the murder and James Henrady's wrongful conviction. Following the meeting, John Lennon and Yoko Ono stunned onlookers as they arrived at the film premiere The Magic Christian. The couple stepped out of their white Rolls-Royce with a banner that read, Britain murdered Henrady. The interest from the superstars renewed public
他说他会让他们与他的富裕邻居联系，这些邻居对詹姆斯的案件很感兴趣。1969年12月9日，亨拉迪夫妇与他们侄子的富裕邻居见了面。约翰·列农和小野洋子，这位前披头士乐队成员对这起案件很感兴趣，并与亨拉迪夫妇进行了长时间的交谈。他们想拍一部关于谋杀案和詹姆斯·亨拉迪被错误定罪的电影。会面后，约翰·列农和小野洋子在电影首映式《魔幻基督徒》亮相时震惊了在场的观众。这对夫妇从他们的白色劳斯莱斯中走出来，拿着一条横幅，上面写着“英国谋杀了好莱坞”——不，是“英国谋杀亨拉迪”。超级巨星们的关注重新燃起了公众对
interest in the case. The couple met often with the Henrady family and a documentary film was produced. However, it was not made accessible to the public. More witnesses came forward to further implicate Peter Alfon as the A6 murderer. The proprietress of the old station in revealed that Alfon was in the pub on the night that Michael and Valerie were having a drink before they were attacked. Still, Scotland Yard declined to reopen the case after a secret police investigation failed to uncover any new compelling evidence to prove Henrady's innocence. To authorities, Peter Alfon was seen as a meddling individual trying to insert himself into the case. In April 1992, the home office was asked to reopen the case after a fresh confession
这起案件的兴趣。这对夫妇经常与亨拉迪一家会面，并制作了一部纪录片。然而，它并未向公众公开。更多的证人站出来，进一步指控彼得·阿尔丰是A6谋杀案的凶手。老车站的女老板透露，在迈克尔和瓦莱里遇袭前喝一杯的那天晚上，阿尔丰就在酒吧里。尽管如此，在一次秘密警方调查未能发现任何能证明亨拉迪无罪的新的令人信服的证据后，苏格兰场拒绝重新审理此案。在当局看来，彼得·阿尔丰被视为一个爱管闲事、企图将自己牵扯进案子的人。1992年4月，在彼得·阿尔丰做出新的供认后，内政部被要求重新审理
from Peter Alfon. This coincided with the release of a television documentary. A review of the documentary in The Guardian said of James Henrady, there cannot be many people left who think he was guilty. Peter Alfon interfered again, sending a greeting card to Michael Gregston's widow Janet, who promptly reported it to the police. Even Janet came forward requesting a posthumous pardon for James Henrady. In April 1994, the case was reopened. An internal inquiry was completed and new evidence gathered. In January 1997, the inquiry concluded that James Henrady was wrongfully hanged. In March 1997, the A6 murder case was handed over from the home office to the newly formed
此案。这与一部电视纪录片的上映巧合。《卫报》对该纪录片的评论称詹姆斯·亨拉迪：“认为他有罪的人已经所剩无几了。”彼得·阿尔丰再次进行干预，给迈克尔·格雷格斯的遗孀珍妮特寄了一张贺卡，珍妮特立即向警方报告了此事。甚至珍妮特也站出来要求为詹姆斯·亨拉迪平反。1994年4月，此案重新开审。内部调查完成，并收集了新的证据。1997年1月，调查得出结论：詹姆斯·亨拉迪是被冤枉绞死的。1997年3月，A6谋杀案从内政部移交给了新成立的
Criminal Cases Review Commission, a statutory body responsible for investigating alleged miscarriages of justice. It took one year, but on March 11, 1998, the Henrady family and supporters heard news from the commission. DNA testing had been completed on two pieces of crime scene evidence that had been kept all these years. They were semen staining from Valerie's underwear and mucus on the handkerchief the murder weapon was found wrapped in. Technology at the time of the shooting was limited. It was only able to ascertain that the male source of the fluids had blood type O. This was James Henrady's blood type, but also Peter Alfons and 36% of the British population.
刑事案件审查委员会，这是一个负责调查涉嫌司法不公的法定机构。花了一年的时间，但在1998年3月11日，亨拉迪一家和支持者听到了委员会的消息。多年来一直保存的两件犯罪现场物证已经完成了DNA检测。它们是瓦莱里内衣上的精液污渍以及发现凶器的手帕上的黏液。枪击发生时的技术有限。它只能确定体液的男性来源血型是O型。这是詹姆斯·亨拉迪的血型，但也是彼得·阿尔丰以及英国36%的人口的血型。
Now, however, technology had advanced to the stage where DNA testing was possible. James Henrady's mother and brother eagerly supplied saliva and blood samples for comparison. The results were inconclusive. In March 1999, the case was handed to the Court of Criminal Appeal. It was widely reported that James Henrady would have his conviction quashed. The Henrady's family solicitor told the Guardian, the amount of information not disclosed by the prosecution at the trial is very substantial. If that material had been disclosed, James Henrady would not have been convicted. James Henrady's family were thrilled with the news.
然而，现在技术已经发展到可以进行DNA检测的阶段。詹姆斯·亨拉迪的母亲和兄弟急切地提供了唾液和血液样本以供比对。结果并不确凿。1999年3月，该案被移交给刑事上诉法院。据广泛报道，詹姆斯·亨拉迪的定罪将被推翻。亨拉迪一家的家族律师告诉《卫报》，控方在审判时未披露的大量信息是非常多的。如果这些材料被披露，詹姆斯·亨拉迪就不会被定罪。詹姆斯·亨拉迪的家人对这个消息感到欣喜若狂。
They told the media that they had been through hell trying to get James posthumously pardoned. Henrady's appeal was set to be heard in December 2000. In July 2000, due to further technological advancements, the DNA samples from the crime scene were able to be examined even further. Peter Alfons supplied his DNA for testing and was officially ruled out as a suspect. His entire confession was a charade. Alfons died in 2009 in London at the age of 79 after suffering a fall. In his later years, he changed his story, coming to vehemently deny any involvement in the A6 murder. Samples provided by the Henrady family were also retested against the specimens from the crime scene.
他们告诉媒体，为了让詹姆斯死后平反，他们经历了人间炼狱。亨拉迪的上诉定于2000年12月审理。2000年7月，由于技术的进一步发展，犯罪现场的DNA样本得以进行更进一步的检测。彼得·阿尔丰提供了他的DNA用于检测，并被官方排除在嫌疑人之外。他整个的供词都是一场骗局。阿尔丰于2009年在伦敦因摔倒去世，享年79岁。在他晚年，他改变了说法，开始强烈否认自己参与了A6谋杀案。亨拉迪家族提供的样本也与犯罪现场的标本进行了重新检测。
The tests came back as a familial match, showing that the semen and mucus samples came from someone related to the Henrady family. Michael Henrady, James' brother, dismissed the results. He called the DNA testing flawed. He stated the samples from the crime scene were stored with samples from James Henrady, allowing cross-contamination to occur. The DNA result showed the odds of Henrady being innocent was one in a billion. In 2001, James Henrady's body was exhumed and re-buried after a DNA sample was extracted from one of his teeth. It was compared against the specimens from the crime scene.
检测结果显示为家族匹配，表明精液和黏液样本来自与亨拉迪家族有亲缘关系的人。詹姆斯的兄弟迈克尔·亨拉迪对结果不予理睬。他称DNA检测是有缺陷的。他声称犯罪现场的样本与詹姆斯·亨拉迪的样本储存在一起，导致交叉污染的发生。DNA结果显示亨拉迪无罪的几率是十亿分之一。2001年，在从他的一颗牙齿中提取了DNA样本后，詹姆斯·亨拉迪的遗体被挖出并重新埋葬。它与犯罪现场的标本进行了比对。
On May 10, 2002, the Court of Criminal Appeal ruled there was evidence that showed, beyond doubt, that James Henrady was guilty of the A6 murder. The argument that the samples might have been contaminated were called fanciful and beyond belief. The judge said that DNA alone proved that James Henrady was guilty of the crime. However, when combined with all of the corroborating evidence, there was overwhelming proof of the safety of the conviction. The ruling put the rest decades of speculation. James Henrady was responsible for the murder of Michael Gregston and the rape and attempted murder of Valerie Storey. Valerie Storey told friends how pleased she was that DNA evidence
2002年5月10日，刑事上诉法院裁定，有证据无可置疑地表明詹姆斯·亨拉迪犯下了A6谋杀案。关于样本可能被污染的争论被称为异想天开、难以置信。法官表示，仅凭DNA就证明了詹姆斯·亨拉迪犯下了罪行。然而，当结合所有佐证时，有压倒性的证据证明定罪是稳妥的。这一裁决平息了数十年的猜测。詹姆斯·亨拉迪对迈克尔·格雷格斯的谋杀以及对瓦莱里·斯托里的强奸和谋杀未遂负有责任。瓦莱里·斯托里向朋友们表达了她对DNA证据感到多么高兴
had proved her right, after many attempts had been made to discredit her by those supporting James Henrady. She never married and continued working as a government scientist, but the decision was made. Having been confined to a wheelchair since age 22, Valerie didn't wallow over what James Henrady had done to her. Instead, she became motivated to better the life of others. She became the director of the Slough Community Transport Service advocating for the physically disabled, a former criminal. She was a former criminal, but she was also a community transport service advocating for the physically disabled, a former colleague and friend stated of Valerie. Being disabled herself, she understood what was needed of our buses,
证明了她是正确的，此前那些支持詹姆斯·亨拉迪的人曾多次试图抹黑她。她从未结婚，继续作为一名政府科学家工作，但决定已经做出。自22岁起就只能坐轮椅，瓦莱里并没有为詹姆斯·亨拉迪对她做过的事而自怨自艾。相反，她积极投身于改善他人生活的事業。她成为了斯劳社区交通服务局的局长，为肢体残疾者发声，曾是一名罪犯——她曾是一名罪犯，但她也是一个为肢体残疾者发声的社区交通服务局的工作人员，一位前同事和朋友这样评价瓦莱里。由于她自己也是残疾人，她理解我们的公交车所需要的是什么，
having used them since she was unable to drive herself anymore. She took on the council over the needs of disabled people. It was her great passion in life. As for her affair with Michael Gregston, Valerie told her friend that she paid a bit of price for what she did. Valerie died in 2016 at age 77. James Henrady's family were unable to accept that he had lied to them and was the perpetrator of the A6 attack. They kept fighting to clear his name, though public support greatly dissipated. The family's refusal to accept James' guilt consumes them and will continue to consume future generations. James' brother Michael spoke on the documentary Murder Casebook
因为她自己无法驾驶后就一直使用它们。她为了残疾人的需求与议会进行了抗争。这是她一生中最大的热情。至于她与迈克尔·格雷格斯的私情，瓦莱里告诉她的朋友，她为自己所做的事付出了一点代价。瓦莱里于2016年去世，享年77岁。詹姆斯·亨拉迪的家人无法接受他曾对他们撒谎并且是A6袭击案的肇事者。尽管公众支持大大消散，他们仍不断为还他清白而斗争。家人拒绝接受詹姆斯有罪的事实，这消耗着他们，并将继续消耗未来的世代。詹姆斯的兄弟迈克尔在纪录片《谋杀案卷》中表示
that when he dies, his sons will take over trying to get justice for James. In the hours before his execution, James Henrady wrote a final letter to his brother Michael. Dear Mike, well Mick, I'm going to do my best to face the morning with courage and strength and I'm sure God will give me the courage to do so. I'm going to ask you to do me a small favour, that is I would like you to try and clear my name of this crime. Someone, somewhere, is responsible for this crime and one day they will venture again and then the truth will come out and then Mick, that will be your chance to step in. I feel the police will try to hush it all up if they get the chance. So Mick, I am counting on you to keep your eyes on the papers.
在他死后，他的儿子们将接替他为詹姆斯争取正义。在行刑前的几个小时里，詹姆斯·亨拉迪给他的兄弟迈克尔写了一封最后的信。亲爱的迈克，好吧，米克，我会尽最大努力以勇气和力量面对清晨，我相信上帝会给我这样做的勇气。我要请你帮我一个小忙，那就是我想请你尽量洗清我在这起罪行上的罪名。有人，在某个地方，对这起罪行负责，总有一天他们会再次铤而走险，然后真相就会大白，到那时，米克，那就是你介入的机会。我觉得如果警方有机会，他们会试图把这一切掩盖起来。所以米克，我指望你盯紧报纸。
Well Mick, with that, time is drawing near. It is almost daylight. I only wish I could have the chance all over again. Mick, I don't know what I've done to deserve this, but Mick, that's fate for you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，米克，话虽如此，时间快到了。天快亮了。我只希望我能有重新来过的机会。米克，我不知道我做了什么才落得这个下场，但米克，这就是你的命运。这个节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。